Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Wenn ihr diesen Sound hört und ungefähr wisst, was das ist, wo es herkommt, warum es jetzt gerade läuft, dann wisst ihr, es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Das ist der Kraftwerk oben des Chaos Radios. Und heute bei mir zu Gast im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon ist Frank Rieger vom Chaos Computer Club.
Guten Abend.
Guten Tag. Und Sargoth, seines Zeichens Administrator der Wikipedia. Dann stellt ihr die Frage, hm, was will der denn hier? Das ist doch normalerweise so, dass hier die Nerds sitzen und irgendwie über Technik reden oder über netzpolitische Themen. Warum schafft denn die jemand von der Wikipedia damit rein? Na ja, das ist sozusagen relativ einfach, wenn ihr die Debatten im Netz ein bisschen verfolgt habt, ist euch vielleicht aufgefallen, dass genau über die Wikipedia gerade ganz ereifert diskutiert wird. Denn es geht darum, dass da bestimmte Dinge in der Wikipedia gelöscht werden. Was man über die Wikipedia weiß, also als ganz normaler Mensch sag ich mal, ist ja so Wikipedia, das ist dieses riesiges Internet-Lexikon, da kann man alles nachlesen und vor allem darf jeder mitmachen und irgendwie auch alles reinschreiben. Das wird dann zwar irgendwie auch korrigiert, aber so grundsätzlich alles geht erstmal. Das ist nicht ganz der Fall. Und wo die Grenzen sind, ob die Grenzen gut sind, wie sie funktionieren, was dafür Leute dahinter stecken und all das werden wir heute klären. Und wir fangen an mit einem Beispiel.
Genau, also der Auslöser für die Wikipedia-Debatte in den Blogs war ja ein Eintrag über den Verein MOGIS, Missbrauchsaufwahl gegen Internetsensur, der im Rahmen der Zensursular-Debatte, also der Debatte darum, ob wir Internet sperren, gegen kinderpornografische Seiten in Deutschland bekommen, relativ wichtig war. Insofern, als das der Christian Bahls, der diese Vereinigung vertritt, da war halt jemand, der tatsächlich selbst betroffener war, der trotzdem sagte, pass auf, es macht keinen Sinn hier eine Zensur einzuführen und wir möchten gerne darüber reden, ohne dass Seiten gesperrt werden. Das war halt extrem wichtig für diese Diskussion. Deswegen haben viele Leute diesen Verein als sehr wesentlich wahrgenommen und der Eintrag in der Wikipedia war halt, naja, der war halt nicht besonders ausführlich und dann wurde er gelöscht und dann gingen die Wellen halt hoch her. Und wir haben Sargoth heute eingeladen, also wir haben bei der Wikipedia gefragt, man kennt sich ja, wer denn Lust hätte, mal beim Chaosradio mitzumachen, um einfach ein paar Sachen zu erklären, ein bisschen zu Positionen auch klar zu machen und auch weit verbreitete Missverständnisse über die Wikipedia so ein bisschen auszuräumen. So und da dachten wir uns, wollen wir mal uns jemand dazu, der tatsächlich drinsteckt, der die Arbeit selber macht und der halt auch in der Lage ist, ja, mal so ein bisschen Binnenperspektive zu geben. Deswegen heute mal eine etwas andere Konstellation als sonst.
Und du hast gerade schon die Geschichte von Moges erzählt, von diesem Verein oder dem Verein, der gerade gegründet wird, aber dessen Artikel auf jeden Fall in der Wikipedia heiß diskutiert ist und der zwar jetzt nicht gelöscht ist, aber ich sage mal für den normalen Benutzer unsichtbar. Du hast erzählt, was dahinter steckt, was passiert ist und warum manche Leute glauben, dass der in der Wikipedia relevant ist. Sargo, erzähl du doch mal die Geschichte dieser Diskussion aus deiner Perspektive.
Also ich habe das erst mitbekommen, was mich eben dem Chat drauf aufmerksam gemacht hat und mir den Link dazu gegeben hat. Dann habe ich mir die Diskussion dazu durchgelesen, den Artikel dazu durchgelesen und habe halt geguckt, gibt es denn da in dem Artikel irgendwas, wo ich sagen würde, okay, das hat eine Bedeutung und gesucht, weitergesucht. Dann haben die Leute gesagt, nein, wir finden noch was. Der Artikel ist bedeutend, dieser Verein ist bedeutend oder diese Website, zumindest diese PR-Kampagne und gibt uns noch Zeit nachzuliefern. Wir zeigen euch auf, dass der Artikel wirklich nützliches Wissen beinhaltet. Und seitdem, ich glaube, das sind ein paar Tage, ich kann das nicht genau sagen, eine Lösch-Diskussion läuft normalerweise sieben Tage, jetzt die Löschprüfung noch mal ein paar Tage, also ich schätze es mal so zwei Wochen ungefähr. Seitdem beobachte ich das halt.
Ja, und die interessante Frage war ja so, was ist denn jetzt relevant? Also wo sind jetzt die Kriterien dafür, dass ein Artikel in die Wikipedia aufgenommen wird? Das würde ich gerne vielleicht nur ein bisschen abstrakter debattieren, bevor wir dann so wieder auf das konkrete Beispiel zurückkommen, weil es gab ja mehrere Diskussionspunkte in dieser Debatte um die Wikipedia. Der erste davon war halt die sogenannte Relevanzdiskussion. Also was macht ein Artikel für würdig, in die Wikipedia aufgenommen zu werden? Vielleicht kannst du das ja noch mal kurz so aus der Sicht der Wikipedia erzählen.
Ja, also im Prinzip finde ich erstmal super, dass überhaupt die Interne der Wikipedia, die halt für viele Leute völlig unbekannt sind, ein bisschen ans Licht gezogen werden. Also es war nie dunkel bei uns im sogenannten Metaraum, der jenseits der Artikel herrscht, aber es war halt immer nur schwach beleuchtet. Und jetzt im Moment ist es halt so, dass wirklich jemand einen Spotlight draufgerichtet hat, jemand, der ein Internetaktivist ist und sagt, hier so seien die Vorgänge in der Wikipedia. Die Relevanzkriterien sind Richtlinien, Maßstäbe, Hinweise und Relevanz bedeutet Bedeutung. Das heißt also, die Leute haben sich über Jahre Gedanken gemacht, wie könnte man versuchen, objektive Anhaltspunkte dafür zu finden, dass ein Artikel, ein Lämmer, so wird ein Thema genannt in der Enzyklopädie Lämmer, dass das auch wirklich bedeutend ist und zwar so bedeutend, dass es auch noch in einiger Zeit bedeutend ist.
Dieses einige Zeit, also ich meine, wenn man es jetzt so angucken, den die Wikipedia hat, ja kann man so ein bisschen salopp sagen, ja den Brockhaus platt gemacht und alle anderen Lexiker im Wesentlichen auch irgendwie erledigt. Also Lexikon auf Papier zu drucken, macht seit die Wikipedia groß geworden, ist in Deutschland keinen Sinn mehr.
Dafür kann man die Wikipedia auf Papier drucken.
Ja, wenn man möchte, aber da sind wir ja genau mitten in diesem Zwiespalt. Das heißt also, ist der Anspruch in der Wikipedia mittlerweile zu sagen, wir ersetzen den Brockhaus? Also ist das der Ziel?
Das ist unerwünscht eigentlich. Also im Prinzip wünschen sich die Leute weiter den Brockhaus, damit sie da halt auch nachgucken können und die Sachen halt eben in die Wikipedia paraphrasieren. Paraphrasieren heißt in eigenen Worten einschreiten.
Also heißt also, dass die Wikipedia eigentlich eher unglücklich darüber ist, dass der Brockhaus jetzt geplättet ist?
Ja, würde ich schon sagen.
Weil plötzlich muss man sich dann mit dem Netz als Quellenraum auseinandersetzen, was ja doch sehr unerwünscht scheint.
Nein, im Prinzip. Also es gibt natürlich immer noch viel Fachliteratur, aber es ist halt schön gewesen, nachzuschlagen einfach, damit man auch eine Idee hat, was ist überhaupt das Zentrale? Was gehört halt ganz oben hin in den Artikel? Was ist das, was ein wirklich professioneller Redakteur für wichtig genug findet, das in einer gedruckten Enzyklopädie halt auch zu verbreiten? Und das fällt halt jetzt leider weg.
Und dann?
Und dann geht es weiter mit uns.
Ich meine, de facto betrachten wir doch gerade genau diesen Punkt, nämlich die Frage, wenn euer zentrales Relevanzkriterium bisher ist, ist auf Totenbaum gedruckt worden. Und ich meine, ich habe gestern gerade mal wieder einen neuen E-Book-Reder in die Hand bekommen. Ist denn das Relevanzkriterium, hat eine ISB-Nummer bekommen oder?
Also nicht unbedingt. Das ist im Prinzip, es gibt Leute, die wirklich sehr hohe, ich nehme mal die Wirtschaftswissenschaften, die haben sehr hohe Qualitätsmaßstäbe, die nehmen wirklich nur Sachen rein, die peer-reviewed sind, das heißt, die einen wissenschaftlichen Diskurs durchlaufen haben, Sachen, die von einem anerkannten Fachmenschen veröffentlicht worden sind und auch von anderen anerkannten Fachmenschen, also Leuten, die wirklich damit ihre Kohle verdienen oder zumindest anerkannt genug sind, um wissenschaftlichen Diskurs mitzumachen, wahrgenommen worden sind und halt auch geprüft.
Aber heißt das dann, dass sie sagen, nur wissenschaftlich ist in Wikipedia? Genau, das heißt es tatsächlich.
In den Wirtschaftswissenschaften gehen die Leute so vor und das klappt gut. Der Rest der Wikipedia sieht teilweise wirklich unter aller Sau aus. Also der Bereich, in dem ich mich bewege, das sind beispielsweise die politischen Wissenschaften, der Artikel Demokratie. In meinen Augen ist das Schrott und der sollte eigentlich gelöscht werden. Den sollte man komplett neu schreiben. Und das ist in anderen Bereichen auch so. Kommunikationswissenschaften und so. Auch in der Philosophie gibt es nur einzelne herausragende Superartikel und der Rest kümmert sich so ein bisschen vor sich hin und keiner schreibt was.
Was ihr gerade diskutiert, sind ja auch Politik, Wissenschaft. Das sind ja die großen Sachen, wo man sagen kann, da gibt es eine Art wissenschaftlichen Diskurs, da gibt es Kriterien, da machen sich große Leute in Mühe drum. Was ist denn mit Dingen, die ihr in den Alltag betreffen, von denen ich aber zum Beispiel erwarten würde, dass sie auch in der Wikipedia drinstehen, diese ganzen Diskussionen um die Löschung ist es ja noch um mehr gegangen als um diesen Verein MOGIS, nämlich zum Beispiel auch um ein Computerspiel. Ja, Brutal Legend heißt es. Das ist ein Computerspiel, das wird seit ungefähr einem Jahr wird da richtig dick darüber berichtet, da sind sehr bekannte Leute dabei gewesen und da hieß es so, ja das Spiel sei nicht relevant genug. Wieso nicht? Also ich meine, man kann ja sozusagen über ein Computerspiel, da gibt es auch noch keine Wissenschaften, so Computerspielwissenschaften gibt es auch nicht. Warum ist sowas nicht relevant genug?
Ja, das messen die Leute dann Verkaufszahlen, aber auch durchaus in Rezensionen oder in Charts zum Beispiel. Also ich habe die Diskussion nicht verfolgt, mir wurde also, ich habe heute nachgelesen auf dem Wiki, dass es darum auch gehen sollte, wenn man Artikel schnell angeguckt und da gibt es irgendwie ab 16, ab 18, keine Ahnung. Also Spiel scheint auch für mich interessant zu sein, aber die Relevanz, also die Lösch-Diskussion habe ich nicht erfolgt, ich habe verfolgt, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die Relevanz-Diskussion ging genauso, wie du es auch gerade angerissen hast. Es gab Leute, die sagten halt Verkaufszahlen, da sagten andere Leute, das ist aber Unsinn, weil es gibt ganz viele andere Werke, einfach von Leuten, die berühmt sind in Kunst oder Film, die da mitgearbeitet haben und schon allein deswegen, weil diese Leute dabei waren, die halt auch Wikipedia-relevant sind, deswegen ist doch das Spiel relevant.
Was war denn im Artikel, wo man sagen würde, okay, das ist der Knackpunkt, das ist die Sache, die wirklich das Spiel innovativ macht, das ist zum Beispiel auch immer eine Sache, also eine neue Engine, so Geschichten irgendwie, oder auch eine komplett neue, total abgedrehte Story oder so. Also irgendwas, was sagt, dieses Spiel ist echt ein Knaller.
Ich möchte kurz sagen, also das Spiel, da geht es darum, dass sozusagen die gesamte Frühgeschichte des Metal in ein Computerspiel verpackt wurde, und zwar auf eine Art und Weise, die sozusagen konsumierbar, erlebbar und aber man lernt auch tatsächlich, was man macht. Das ist also sagen der innovative Ansatz. Aber mal abgesehen davon, dass man jetzt über dieses Spiel natürlich noch lange diskutieren könnte, was ist denn mit solchen Themen? Es wird ja noch andere Themen geben, wo Leute sagen, hey, ich finde, das ist wichtig, das müsste da stehen, da will ich mich informieren, aber es wird gelöscht.
Ja, also ich habe es versucht, dir so ein bisschen irgendwie klar zu machen, weil die Diskussion hängt sich oft an diesen Relevanzkriterien auf, was daran liegt, dass die Leute sehr häufig feste Orte suchen, Maßstäbe suchen oder denken, okay, hier ist sozusagen die Wand, an die ich einreißen kann oder an was weiß ich, wo ich dich verschieben kann oder wie auch immer. Ein Admin, der so eine Löschdiskussion abarbeitet, der guckt schon auch immer auf die Relevanzkriterien, dann kann er gleich sagen, okay, eigentlich im Grunde, da steht drin irgendwie, das Spiel müsste so und so viel verkauft, ist er doppelt so viel verkauft, bleibt, kein Problem. Erfüllt es diese Kriterien nicht, muss irgendjemand in dieser Diskussion Sachargumente vorbringen, die deutlich machen, dass der Artikel zu dem Spiel nützliches Wissen darstellt.
Das heißt aber sozusagen, also ein wichtiger Punkt, den wir jetzt gerade lernen ist, in der Wikipedia gilt sozusagen nicht die Unschuldsvermutung für Artikel, sondern ein Artikel muss beweisen, dass er was wert ist, bevor er bleiben darf. Das noch kurz, bevor Frank da schon ganz ungeduldig ist, du kannst gleich einsprechen. Vorher möchte ich noch eine Sache sagen, denn wir drei im Studio überhaken und jetzt über diese Wikipedia stehen wir schon ganz ganz ausführlich, aber es gibt natürlich noch mehr Leute, die es interessiert, und das habt ihr dort draußen. Für die gilt erst mal folgendes. Es ist nämlich so, dass wir in dem Radio auch ein Telefon haben und das könnt ihr anrufen und könnt uns zum Beispiel erzählen, wie ihr die Wikipedia erlebt habt. Also ob ihr schon mal was eingeschaltet habt, was gelöscht wurde, ob ihr die Sachen nicht findet, die ihr sucht, oder ob ihr total zufrieden damit seid, oder ob ihr zu dem hier diskutierten löschen oder nicht löschen auch eine Meinung habt. Die Leitungen sind offen, ihr könnt auch im Chat mitmachen, den Link dazu, also wie auch zur Wiki-Seite, es gibt auch noch eine Wiki-Seite zu dieser Chaosradio-Sendung, gibt es auf Chaosradio.de. Ihr habt jetzt alle Kanäle, ihr seid relevant genug, also ruft gefälligst an.
Genau, und bis die Leitungen voll werden, was wir doch mal hoffen, würde ich gerne noch mal auf diesen Punkt zurückkommen. Du sagtest ja, dass deine Spezialität Sozialwissenschaften-Politik, also Artikel, die jetzt nicht, sagen wir mal, harte Wissenschaften sind, sondern mehr so angewandte Zeitgeschichte aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht betrachtet. Genau da scheint mir bei der Wikipedia momentan jetzt das größte Kollisionspotenzial mit dem Rest der Netzgesellschaft zu sein, sondern in dem Sinne, dass das Netz es so empfindet, dass Relevanz im Wesentlichen durch Aufmerksamkeit zustande kommt. Also Themen, die eine hohe Aufmerksamkeit erzielen, die eine große Verbreitung erzielen, wo viele Leute kommentieren, wo viele Leute sich für engagieren, sind erst mal per se wichtiger, als ob jetzt irgendwie ein Ministerpräsidenten Forz gelassen hat und das auf der dpa gemeldet wird. Also jetzt von der gefühlten Wichtigkeit her. Und mir scheint, dass da so ein bisschen so einer der Kernkonfliktpunkte jetzt bei den letzten Diskussionen, die jetzt so durch die Vlogs gingen, ist, dass genau da diese gefühlte Wichtigkeit in der Wikipedia so genau gar nicht reflektiert wird, außer jetzt mal über Verkaufszahlen.
Ja, ja mal das Problem, dass es Lebenswelten gibt, in denen die Leute sich aufhalten. Und wenn du beispielsweise in Kleinsiesten wohnst bis seit 30 Jahren aktiv in der freiwilligen Feuerwehr, hast mal den zweiten Platz gemacht in der Dorfschützenmeisterschaft, dann ist das deine Welt. Dann ist das unheimlich wichtig. Dann ist es das, womit du dich mit deinen Freunden austauschst. Und es sind auch die Leute aus dem Kreis, die zu deiner Beerdigung kommen. Das heißt, du willst auch unbedingt einen Artikel in der Wikipedia haben. Und diese Leute bewegen uns auch.
Na gut, aber es ist ja schon mal ein Unterschied zwischen 250.000 FIFA-Block-Lesern und 25 Mitgliedern der lokalen Freiwillige Feuerwehr.
Wobei, ich finde auch schon, da ist die spannende Frage, was schadet es? Also was schadet es, einen Artikel über diese Freiwillige Feuerwehr in Kleinsieße nicht zu haben?
Das schadet in dem Moment, in dem jemand einen Artikel lesen will über die Freiwillige Feuerwehr in Kleinsieße nicht. Und den hat irgendwann mal jemand angelegt. Es steht halt eben nur Müll drin. Es können sogar gefährliche Sachen drin stehen. Wenn wir mal bei der Feuerwehr sind, die beschreiben ja immer im Detail, welche Einsatzfahrzeuge die haben und denen sind die gar nicht verfügbar oder so. Da ruft da jemand an und denkt irgendwie, die können ihm jetzt sein Feuer retten und das können sie nicht. Also wir haben und wir möchten ja wissen, dass auch einigermaßen geprüft ist, nur darstellen.
Ja, aber da müsste man ja jetzt sagen, Moment mal, da gibt es aber, also das gilt ja für jeden Artikel.
Ja, genau. Und die Leute kümmern sich auch um den Artikel, lesen die halt eben durch, schauen auch nach, ob die Sachen stimmen. Die Leute schlagen auch in Büchern rein. Also es ist ganz oft, habe ich das schon mitbekommen, dass jemand irgendeine Quelle zu irgendeinem Beleg zitiert hat und falsch zitiert hat. Da hat jemand wirklich nachgeschlagen, auf der Seite festgestellt. Der Autor hat genau das Gegenteil geschrieben. Diese Geschichten kannst du nicht mehr machen, wenn du Milliarden von Artikeln hast. Das geht noch, jetzt im Moment haben wir eine knappe Million. Da haut das noch so halbwegs hin mit ein paar Tausend Leuten, die sich drum kümmern. Aber wenn das halt ausufert, dann kann ich mir nicht mehr vorstellen, dass da wirklich die Sachen halbwegs geprüft sind. Also, Wikipedia, nichts glauben, was drin steht, aber doch zumindest mal denken, okay, das ist ein Anhaltspunkt.
Aber wäre es nicht einfacher, wenn man sagt, naja, wenn es viele Artikel gibt, gibt es auch viele Leute, die sich drum kümmern. Im Moment schreckt dir vielleicht einfach Leute ab oder...
Ich würde sagen, das ist schon so.
Greifst du jetzt ein bisschen vor, vielleicht können wir den Punkt ein bisschen weiter hinten diskutieren.
Na gut.
Warum da zu wenig Leute sind. Haben wir ein paar Hörer oder ruft keiner an?
Wir haben auch noch ein paar Hörer, klar.
Lass uns doch mal kurz eine kleine Runde Hörer machen.
Leon zum Beispiel ist erst 14, hat aber schon dick in der Wikipedia mitgemacht, wie er zu Ohren gekommen ist.
Guten Abend.
Hallo, deine Erlebnisse mit der Wikipedia sind?
Ich habe einmal einen Artikel angelegt, bei einem Filmfestival, ein Jugendfilmfestival, bei dem ich mitmache. Und das ist in der Szene doch recht groß, weil die ist nicht so besonders groß, die Jugendfilmmacherszene. Und das wurde dann gelöscht wegen irrelevanten. Eigentlich möchte ich folgendes machen. Ich bin ein Autor und ich lege einen Artikel an. Ich gebe Quellen an, ich kann mit dem verifizieren und dann möchte ich nicht rausfliegen wegen irrelevant. Und ich möchte mir auch gar nicht einarbeiten mit Kriterien, ob jetzt ein Filmfestival irrelevant ist, weil Leute, die außerhalb von bestimmten sozialen Gruppen sind, können das ja gar nicht beurteilen. Ich als Wikipedia-Admin kann ich beurteilen, wie ein Filmfestival, was in der Jugendszene irgendwie gegründet wurde, welche Relevanz es jetzt hat, weil ich mich in dieser Szene gar nicht auskenne. Und deswegen finde ich, dass es auch jeweils Experten für solche Bereiche gibt. Sowas gibt es ja. Es gibt ja Abnehmensvollbereiche, weil das noch länger aufgespielt wird.
Sargo, du hast gerade irgendwie als er anfing mit ich habe einen Jugendfilmfestival, da hast du bedächtig mit dem Kopf genickt.
Ich habe bedächtig mit dem Kopf genickt? Ich weiß nicht. Ich finde es halt nur schade, weil er sich ja wirklich Mühe gemacht hat und offensichtlich auch kapiert hat, woraus ein Artikel bestehen sollen. Dass er dann gelöscht wird, tut man natürlich leid für ihn.
Was macht man in so einem Fall?
Das ist jetzt sehr schwer. Ich würde ihm raten, zu gucken, was im Artikel Jugend Film Festival, wenn es den überhaupt gibt, ob es da nicht möglich ist, einen kleinen Abschnitt zu diesem Festival zu machen, wenn es halt eines der wenigen gibt. Ich gehe mal davon aus, es gibt nur drei, vier. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ja, dann weiß ich nicht. Also dann macht es sicher Sinn, das zu erwähnen. Vor allen Dingen, ich weiß nicht, wie lange gibt es das denn schon? Ja, also konkret, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, wir haben nicht mal konkrete Kriterien für Festivals. Also es geht bei so kommerziellen Veranstaltungen, sind natürlich Kriterien da, weil die Leute halt immer ein Interesse verfolgen. Aber in dem konkreten Fall, weiß ich nicht, bist du zur Möschprüfung gegangen?
Hast du noch mal nachgeguckt?
In dem Moment war es mir egal. Weil eigentlich gebe ich als Autor die Wikipedia-Zeit. Ich werde in der Arbeitszeit auf. Der Artikel war eigentlich von den allgemeinen Artikeln, also es gibt ja so Artikel, die geschrieben werden, war der eigentlich okay. Und in dem Gefühl, eigentlich war Grauze Wikipedia so seine Autoren. Weil man steckt Arbeit, der was ist, weg. Aber ich kann noch mal ein zweites Beispiel bringen. Ich war vor zwei Wochen auf dem Webmontag hier in Berlin. Das ist so ein jeden Monat ein Treffen, ein paar Stunden diskutieren mit anderen Internet-Interessierten. Und da haben wir eine Diskussion über die Wikipedia-Sache geführt. Und eine Frau, das Beispiel gebracht, ihre Mutter, macht einen Kurs für Gebärtshelferinnen. Also für Geburts- Das ist jetzt in die richtige Zeit gesetzt, das ist jetzt auch egal. Und das hat sehr entscheidend, dass man eine bestimmte Ausbildung hat, weil dieser Beruf begriffenlich geschützt ist.
Also jeder kann sie so nennen.
Und dann wurde der Artikel gelöscht, weil so angeblich Werbung. Und das war wieder ein Admin, der keine Ahnung von nichts in diesem Bereich hatte und sich trotzdem gewillig fühlt, diesen Artikel zu löschen.
Der Artikel war über die Firma?
Über den Kursgang, nicht mal über die Firma, sondern über den Kursgang und was man dann praktisch gemacht hat. Also was man dann für einen Zertifikaten, wenn man diesen Kurs fertig hat.
Also über die Qualifikation befasst. Genau.
Und eine ganz allgemeine Frage, warum soll man mit was löschen? Also der Speicherplatz ist ja praktisch unendlich. Und wenn ein Artikel in allgemeinen Kriterien spricht, also Quellen, Nachweisbar und so weiter, dann finde ich so das Kriterium relevant eigentlich gar nicht mehr geben. Weil ich glaube im Not Safe Work Podcast von Tim Pütlarf und Tolgi, die haben dann gesagt, Tim könnte auch einen Artikel über sein Auto schreiben und es interessiert vielleicht fünf Leute. Aber es stört die anderen 82 Millionen Leute, die sie nicht angucken. Es stört sie auch nicht, dass der Artikel da ist.
Ja, aber Wikipedia ist keine Datenbank, ist keine gelben Seiten. Wikipedia ist kein Personenverzeichnis, sondern ist eine Enzyklopädie.
Aber wie definiert sie eine Enzyklopädie? Ist eine Sammlung von Alltagswissen.
Leon, das ist genau das, was wir heute diskutieren wollen. Ich würde dich jetzt noch gerne kurz fragen. Du hast jetzt sozusagen zwei Erfahrungen gemacht mit der Wikipedia. Würdest du noch einen dritten Versuch unternehmen oder hast du jetzt genug?
Ich habe ein paar Mal Artikel verbessert. Das wurde dann noch, glaube ich, nicht gelöscht. Ich werde vielleicht noch mal ein paar Bilder zu Wikipedia hinzufügen. Aber Artikel eröffnen werde ich nicht mehr, weil ich einfach keinen Stress haben möchte.
Alles klar, das würde ich jetzt an dieser Stelle erst mal so stehen lassen. Vielen Dank Leon und hoffentlich wird nicht noch mehr gelöscht. Wir nehmen jetzt noch kurz den Andre dran, der uns was zur Relevanz erzählen will.
Hi, mir geht es also wie dem Vorredner in Bezug auf Relevanz. Ich finde auch, dass das Relevanzthema irgendwo nicht, naja, sollte kaum Beachtung finden. Vielleicht sollte man Relevanz messen an den Zugriffszahlen. Dass man zum Beispiel sagt, wir sagen jetzt, das sind Artikel erstellt worden. Wir gucken uns jetzt fast natürlich an, ob das alles richtig ist, etc. ob die Form eingehalten wurde. Und dann kann man halt mal, was weiß ich, ein halbes Jahr abwarten und schauen, ob da x Leute drauf zugegriffen haben oder nicht.
Ist das machbar?
Und damit dann das jetzt zu erklären.
Das ist schon eine ganz gute Idee. Also wir machen das im Prinzip so, wir gucken, wie viele Seiten verlinken drauf. Da siehst du zwar nicht jetzt, wie das allgemeine Interesse ist, weil es kann ja auch ein Hype sein, sondern du siehst, wie allgemein überhaupt das Interesse in der Wikipedia schon mal ist, dass ein Artikel zu dem Thema geschrieben wird. Das ist sowas Ähnliches.
Ein Hype erkennt man ja dann auch an den Zugriffszahlen. Wenn auf einmal im ersten Monat 20.000 Zugriffe sind und danach ist es halt weniger.
Wir löschen ja nichts mehr, was einmal durch die Löschdiskussion gekommen ist. Das behalten wir halt eben alles.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht. Ich finde das schon ein Thema ist relevant, wenn sich jemand die Mühe macht und zu dem Thema einen Artikel erstellt, weil das ist eine Haufen Arbeit. Das ist nicht mit einer halben Stunde getan. Also wenn jemand den Geist von Wikipedia oder vom Netz irgendwo inne hat, dann macht er sich die Mühe und formuliert den auch vernünftig etc. etc. Ich weiß nicht, dann hat jemand schon so viel Arbeit da reingesteckt, das ist eigentlich, ja, weiß nicht, dann beweist für mich schon die Relevanz an sich.
Ja, André, erstmal vielen Dank. Wir werden das besprechen. Wir sind jetzt schon quasi fast wieder ein bisschen in Zeitnot. Auf jeden Fall taucht eine Frage immer wieder auf, das ist nämlich das, ist es nicht möglich, dass wir einfach unendlich viele Artikel in der Wikipedia haben? Kannst du da nochmal das zusammenfassen? Du bist ja der Admin, du arbeitest bei der Wikipedia.
Ich denke noch, dass über den letzten Anrufer nach. Unendlich viele Artikel in der Wikipedia, es gibt erstmal unendlich viele Artikel, die noch gewünscht sind. Das ist nicht der Punkt, es ist unglaublich viel Arbeit noch zu machen. Wir haben ja in der englischsprachigen, glaube ich drei Millionen derzeit, in Deutschland knapp ein Millionen und das wird nie aufhören. Es passiert ja jedes Jahr passieren neue Sachen, es gibt auch neue Forschungsergebnisse, das heißt die Erkenntnisse über alte Sachen erfordern auch neue Lämmer, also das wird nicht aufhören zu wachsen. Insofern ist dieses unendlich klar mit Ja zu beantworten. Unendlich viele Lämmer, die kein nützliches Wissen beherbergen.
Ja was ist denn da nützlich? Also ich meine, das ist ja so ein, ihr habt es vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt im Vorgespräch, ich habe da zu Hause von 1858 ein Meyers-Konversations-Lexikon, das erscheint tatsächlich oder erschien damals auf Papier jährlich, also ein echt dicker, fetter Wälzer, so in Leder gebunden. Und in dem steht irgendwie alles drin, was in dem Jahr, also in dem Jahr davor, interessant wurde. Also da war halt so einfach die Dinge, die man wissen musste, um aktuell mitreden zu können. Deswegen der Name Konversations-Lexikon. So, es war gedacht als Add-on zu einem normalen Lexikon. Und eigentlich ist es doch die wahrgenommene Funktion der Wikipedia, zumindest von vielen Leuten wahrgenommene Funktion, wenn ich einen neuen Begriff höre, den ich bisher noch nicht habe, also gehört habe, dann gehe ich in die Wikipedia um zu gucken, was es ist. Und eigentlich will ich es auch nicht googeln, sondern ich gehe halt direkt zur Wikipedia, weil da erwarte ich eine knappe kurze Auskunft, wo zumindest schon mal zwei Leute gegenlesen haben. Also das ist zumindest so das Nutzungsgefühl, was die allermeisten Leute haben. Demgegenüber steht jetzt so dieser hohe Nutzwert-Anspruch, der halt einfach so überhaupt nicht mit der Realität, also mit der Alltagsrealität der meisten Wikipedianutzer zu tun hat.
Wir haben also die große Frage eigentlich, sozusagen Alltagsrealität gegen großen wissenschaftlichen Anspruch. Und weil Sargo gerade im Prinzip der Einzige ist, der hier so eine Seite vertrifft und es von allen Seiten dick bekommt, würde ich ihm jetzt gerne ein bisschen Zeit zum Nachdenken geben. Wir müssen auch gleich noch Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr machen. Vorher möchte ich allerdings einen Song präsentieren. Ja, wir werden heute auch ein bisschen Musik machen. Und der passt wirklich also zum Thema, also quasi wie die Relevanz in die Wikipedia oder wie auch immer das heißt.
Ich habe keinen Eintrag bei Wikipedia, drum frage ich mich manchmal, bin ich wirklich da? Bin ich wirklich existent oder bilde ich mir nur ein? Denn wäre es so, da müsste Eintrag doch da sein. Ich habe keinen Eintrag bei Wikipedia, ich kann doch nicht real sein, das ist schon mal klar. Meine Existenz ist für mich höchst umstritten und suche ich bei Google, wird auch schwer gelitten. Nicht mal tausend Treffer, was heißt das hier schon? Bei Milliarden Seiten scheint das fast wie hohen. Nur weil da mein Name steht, steht da noch nichts über mich. Und in der Bildersuche sieht keiner mein Gesicht. Ich habe keinen Eintrag bei Wikipedia, drum frage ich mich manchmal, bin ich wirklich da? Bin ich wirklich existent oder bilde ich es mir nur ein? Denn wäre es so, dann müsste Eintrag doch da sein. Bei YouTube läuft kein Video mit mir im Abspann. Das wär immer in eine Deets, du bist am Leben an. Im Duden such ich vergeblich, naja, was zu erwarten. Telefonbuch gibt mir Hoffnung und Branchenbücherarten. Doch das ist alles regional und vielleicht gefälscht. Es gibt nur eine Sache, die als Beweis zählt. Neben Sigmund Freud bei Dummer und Plektrum sollte doch auch richtig Wikipedia ergo summen. Ich habe keinen Eintrag bei Wikipedia. Drum frag ich mich manchmal, bin ich wirklich da? Bin ich wirklich existent oder bilde ich mir nur ein? Denn wäre es so, dann müsste Eintrag doch da sein. Ich habe keinen Eintrag bei Wikipedia. Drum frag ich mich manchmal, bin ich wirklich da? Bin ich wirklich existent oder bilde ich mir nur ein? Denn wäre es so, dann müsste Eintrag doch da sein.
Der arme Mr. Renz hat keinen Eintrag in Wikipedia und besinkt das auf eine sehr schöne Art und Weise. Den Link zum MP3 gibt es auf der Wikiseite zur Sendung. Das ist Chaosradio151, das ihr hört. Und den Link dort hin findet ihr auf Chaosradio.de. Bevor wir weiter über die Wikipedia reden, machen wir aber erst mal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Manchmal kommt neue Musik nicht aus den Charts, sondern genau dahin, wo ihr wohnt.
Auch nach Eberswalde? Um kurz nach halb elf.
Die neue Bundesregierung hat heute ihre Arbeit aufgenommen. Das Kabinett kam am späten Nachmittag zu einer kurzen Sitzung zusammen. Davor hatten die 15 Minister des Kabinetts ihren Amtsalt abgelegt und von Bundespräsident Köhler die Ernennungsurkunde erhalten. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel wurde am Vormittag vom Bundestag für eine zweite Amtszeit gewählt. Am Abend traf sie im Rahmen ihrer ersten Auslandsreise nach der Wiederwahl in Paris ein. In Brandenburg haben sich SPD und Linke auf die Verteilung der Ministerposten verständigt. Die Sozialdemokraten erhalten fünf Ministerien. Die Linke übernimmt als neuer Koalitionspartner vier Ministerposten. Der bisherige Finanzminister Speer von der SPD wechselt in das Innenressort. Neue Wissenschaftsministerin wird seine Parteigenosse in Münch. Bildungsminister Ruprecht behält sein Amt. Die Linke übernimmt unter anderem die Ministerien für Wirtschaft und für Umwelt. Die Berliner Humboldt-Uni und die Münchner Ludwig-Maximilians-Uni haben bei einem neuen Hochschulvergleich in Deutschland am besten abgeschnitten. Das teilte das Zentrum für Hochschulentwicklung der Bertelsmann Stiftung mit. Es ging um die Studienbedingungen für Masterstudenten und Promovierende. An 100 europäischen Hochschulen waren die Fächer Volkswirtschaftslehre, Psychologie und Politikwissenschaft untersucht worden. Heute Nacht, da ist es ziemlich bewölkt draußen. Es kann immer wieder regnen. Und die Temperaturen, die gehen heute Nacht bis auf 6 Grad zurück. Hier sind die aktuellen Werte. In Cottbus und Angermünde, da sind es noch 8 Grad. In Potsdam, Frankfurt, Neuropin und Wittenberge, da sind es 9. Und auch in Berlin haben wir so zwischen 9 und 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann in der ersten Tageshefte weiterhin sehr bewirkt sein. Später am Nachmittag lockert es dann weiter vom Osten wieder ein bisschen auf. Und es wird wieder ein bisschen kühler als heute mit Höchstwerten von gerade mal 11 Grad. Vorsicht bitte auf der Stadt Autobahn, A111, statt einwärts zwischen Weidmanns-Rüster-Damm, Hermsdorfer-Damm und Holzhäuser Straße. Da ist gesperrt, weil da gebaut wird. A114, Zubringer Pankow statt einwärts, zwischen der Passewerker Straße und der Prenzlauer Promenade. Auch da ist durch eine Baustelle gesperrt, A111, Stadt Autobahn, Richtung Süden, zwischen Weidmanns-Rüster-Damm und dem Festplatz. Auch da ist Richtung Stadt einwärts gesperrt, da ist eine Umleitung beschildert. Und noch eine letzte Meldung, die kommt von der Berliner U-Bahn, zwischen dem Gleisdreig und dem Bittenbergplatz. Da fahren auf der U1 keine Züge, bitte weicht da auf die Linie U2 aus und der Bahnhof Kurfürstenstraße, der ist geschlossen. Und bei der U8 wird seit 22 Uhr zwischen Cottbuser Tor und Heinrich-Heine-Straße mit Bussen gependelt, da wo es geht euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz im Berliner Kabel.
Mit Markus Richter, Frank Rieger vom Chaos Computer Club und Sargo von der Wikipedia. Und wir reden heute darüber, wie es in der Wikipedia zugeht. Wie werden dort Artikel beurteilt? Was wird behalten? Was wird einfach so gelöscht? Und wir wollen auch von euch wissen, wie sind eure Erfahrungen mit der Wikipedia? Habt ihr schon mal was am Startkart, wo ihr dachtet, hey, das will ich unbedingt drin haben? Und dann habt ihr euch lange Arbeit gemacht und dann hat es irgendwie, es ist einfach wieder gelöscht worden, obwohl ihr dachtet, hey, das ist wirklich wichtig. Oder denkt ihr, mann, Wikipedia, das sind eh alle Spinner, das sollte man sowieso alles zusammenlöschen, einfach den irgendeinen Papierlexikon abschreiben, weil da steht sowieso drin, was gehen soll.
Wir wollen auch wissen, ob euch Wikipedia zum Beispiel schon mal den Arsch gerettet hat. Gibt's ja auch.
Die hab ich ganz vergessen. Die Studienarbeit aus der, nein, das hab ich nicht gesagt. Wir waren vor der Nachricht stehen geblieben mit, es gibt so den Konflikt zwischen einer Alltagsrelevanz, also einfach Dinge, die Leute in ihrem Alltag erleben, wo sie denken, das ist wichtig, das sollten Leute wissen. Frank hat das Konversationslexikon aus dem 18. Jahrhundert angeführt. 19. Jahrhundert. So eine Art Anleitung, wie man cool auf Party mit Fachwissen angeben kann, was gerade noch aufkommt. Wie war das mit der Aalleiter?
Genau, der erste Interesse ist die Aalleiter. Also es hand sich dabei um ein Gerät, das man in Bachstufen versenken kann, damit die Aale es halt auch noch irgendwie über diese Bachstufe weiter nach oben in den See oder so ähnlich schaffen.
Deswegen gleich direkte Frage an Sargo. Wenn so ein Artikel jetzt in der Wikipedia sozusagen auftauchen würde, was wäre damit?
Ja, ich denke, das ist ein klassisches schönes Ding. Das würde auf jeden Fall behalten werden. Also es hat ja wohl jemand irgendwann erfunden im 19. Jahrhundert oder 18.
Ich hab das jetzt nicht ganz mitbekommen.
Im 19. Jahrhundert ist es eine Innovation. Auch die Firma, die das erfunden hat, würde wahrscheinlich behalten werden.
Tja, aber zum Beispiel halt, naja, also so ein Eintrag wie der Chunk zum Beispiel nicht.
Na, der Chunk nicht, nee.
Bevor wir uns jetzt sozusagen in eine dreistündige Diskussion darüber ereilen, ob es einen Wikipedia-Eintrag über Chunk geben sollte, wer von euch beiden erklärt, was das ist?
Also ich weiß es, also ich hab ja noch nicht getrunken, also Chunk ist ein Club-Mate-basiertes Cocktailgetränk, das beruht auf Club-Mate, Eishofen, Limetten, Zucker und wahlweise braunen oder weißen Rum, die dann in einem bestimmten Verhältnis gemischt werden und das wirkt sowohl anregend als auch alkoholisierend, weil der Alkohol und das Koffein in der Club-Mate zusammen doch eine sehr angenehm berauschende...
Ist das ein Aphrodisi...
Entschuldigung?
Es handelt sich nur um... Also wir dürfen keine Alkoholwaggen machen.
Würde ich also sagen, wie heißt das in der Wikipedia? So schön, der Neutral Point of View?
Ja, das war tatsächlich das Werbeteam-Zitat aus dem ehemaligen Wikipedia-Tipp. Aber die Löschdiskussion geht noch bis Freitag und ich hab für diese Woche noch auf der Liste ein Video-Interview mit dem Erfinder des Getränkes, um mal zu gucken, ob es denn ausreicht als Relevanzkriterium.
Okay, es geht also wie um ein Cocktail.
Genau. Wo wir gerade waren bei der Altersrelevanz, das Problem, was die Wikipedia ja hat, ist, dass sie ja wichtiger wird, als sie eigentlich lieb ist. Ich hab gerade schon erwähnt, ich hab mir gerade diese Woche ein aktuelles E-Book Reading Device gekauft, was auch einen Webbrowser drauf hat, nur dieser Webbrowser kastriert. Der kann nicht webbrausen, weil sonst der Hersteller dieses Gerätes halt zu viel roaming-Gebühren zahlen würde im Funknetz, also zu viel Datentarife. Aber was funktioniert, ist tatsächlich die englische Wikipedia. Das ist die einzige Webseite, auf die ich mit diesem Gerät online zugreifen kann, ist die englische Wikipedia. Das heißt also, wenn ich unterwegs bin irgendwo, dann kann ich nicht googeln, ich kann tatsächlich nur auf die Wikipedia klicken. Und noch so ein anderes Beispiel war jetzt eine Firma, die hat ein Wikipedia-Device herausgebracht. Also so ein kleines 99-Dollar-Device, auf dem sich jeweils ein vierteljährlich aktualisiertes Snapshot von der englischen Wikipedia befindet. Und ich finde, das ist halt so ein klares Zeichen dafür, dass so ein Brockhaus-Wissenschaftsanspruch halt vielleicht nicht mehr ausreicht.
Nö, ich hab selbst bei dem Artikel Krocher irgendwie mir die Kante gegeben. Und da in dem Fall war ich nur einer der sozusagen niedrigsten Benutzer, weil ich halt ums Verrecken dafür gekämpft hab, dass dieser Artikel behalten wird, weil ich der Meinung war, Krocher, es gab seit, ich weiß nicht, ob es überhaupt jemals in der Weltgeschichte eine originäre österreichische Jugend, österreichische Jugendbewegung gab. Aber ich meine, das ist relevant. Okay, die Leute laufen genauso rum wie in Neukölln irgendwie mit Neon-Kappen und verschiedensten Klamotten und sehen eigentlich überhaupt nicht anders aus. Aber irgendwie ist das eine Jugendkultur. Und ich habe wirklich genau so in der Löschdiskussion dafür argumentiert, den Artikel verbessert, versucht irgendwelche Belege dazu zu finden, dass es auch in den Medien gespiegelt wurde und hatte erst in dem Moment gewonnen, als es irgendwie Wort drei des Jahres oder so in Österreich geworden ist, die Krocher.
Das ist aber eine interessante Einschätzung, die du jetzt gerade machst, weil du sagst, so wie du es erzählst, wie du dich jetzt anhörst, es ist sozusagen so, ja das ist doch irgendwie was Tolles, das ist doch irgendwie relevant. Das selbe könnte man auch irgendwie für Moge sagen.
Genau, also das, natürlich, ich kenne die Position auch aus der anderen Seite. Ich schreibe ja auch Artikel, es ist ja nicht so, dass mir auch keine Sachen gelöscht worden sind. Ein Artikel gammelte zwei Jahre bei mir im Benutzernahmensraum rum. Das ist sozusagen ein Raum neben dem Artikelraum, in dem man Sachen zwischenlagern kann.
Okay, ich höre mal Raum, aber eigentlich...
Ja, warte mal ganz kurz. Nur irgendwann wurde der Artikel relevant, weil die Kriterien geändert wurden.
Moment, das heißt, du hast dein Artikel gewartet, bis sich irgendwie die Regel geändert hat?
Es war Zufall. Es ging um einen Verlag und die Verlagsteilung.
Jetzt aber bitte noch mal zurück zum Raum.
Genau, das müsste ich mit dem Benutzernahmensraum erklären.
Das ist so eine Metaebene. Was hat das auf sich?
Also, die Wikipedia unterscheidet in verschiedene Räume. Wir nennen die Namensräume, da gibt es erstmal den Raum ohne Namen, das ist der Artikelnahmensraum, den nennt man Artikelnahmensraum, damit man ihn unterscheiden kann. Dann gibt es den Benutzernahmensraum, das ist alles, was mit Benutzerdoppelpunkt anfängt. Das ist alles der Benutzernahmensraum. Dann gibt es den Wikipedianahmensraum, alle Seiten, die mit Wikipedia-Doppelpunkt anfangen und den Hilfenahmensraum, alles, was mit Hilfe-Doppelpunkt anfängt.
Könnte man sich das so vorstellen wie so eine Art Unterteilung?
Genau.
Also sagen, die Artikel selber sind das, was alle sehen können und der Rest ist sozusagen so ein bisschen versteckter.
Richtig.
Was heißt es, wenn ein Artikel im Benutzernahmensraum ist?
Im Benutzernahmensraum kann man den zum Beispiel ausbauen. Also ich habe derzeit zwei Artikel im Benutzernahmensraum, die da auch schon länger rumgammeln, weil ich irgendwie nicht dazu komme, die auszubauen und kann mir im Prinzip länger Zeit nehmen dafür. Also es gibt auch einige Leute, die versuchen da irgendwelche Sachen zu verstecken oder so. Weil das Google-indiziert wird, dann wird es aber doch gefunden und wenn man halt ernsthaft daran arbeitet, dann ist das halt eine gute Sache und nur irgendwas zu verstecken, bringt es das halt nicht.
Das heißt also, das ist der Punkt, wenn ich einen Artikel schreiben will und ich weiß, ich schaffe nicht, sozusagen jetzt irgendwie in ein paar Stunden zu rocken, dann tue ich den bei mir in den Benutzernahmensraum und arbeite dort.
Genau.
Was meinst du, wie viele Leute, die zum ersten Mal auf der Wikipedia sind oder die einfach so nutzen, wissen überhaupt, dass es das gibt?
Null.
Sollte man das dann nicht irgendwie ändern?
Ja, also mir ist es auch am Anfang so passiert, das war halt eben mit meinem Artikel, da war der Freundliche Admin und der hat mir halt in den Benutzernahmensraum geschoben und hat gesagt, ich soll halt da weiter dran arbeiten und dann mal gucken, ob ich den irgendwann wieder rausschieben kann. Ich hab natürlich auch überhaupt nichts verstanden, aber ich war halt sehr dankbar, dass der Artikel nicht gelöscht worden ist, weil ich dachte zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch, alles was gelöscht ist, ist gelöscht, ist aber gar nicht so, ist alles noch da, ist nur versteckt.
So, die Frage, die ich mir ja gestellt habe, ist, wenn das so kommt mit dem Löschen, jetzt hab ich den Faden verloren. Oh nein, ich bin nicht mehr relevant.
Dann lass uns doch mal Blaine reinnehmen, der wartet schon auf uns.
Hi Blaine.
Hi, ja ich wollte mich mal kurz zu Wort melden, weil ich diese Sache jetzt schon seit einigen Wochen verfolge. Also ich denke mal, sowohl in der Wikipedia als auch auf der anderen Seite, von der ja hauptsächlich die Kritik kommt, kennt man mich ein bisschen. Ich hab sehr aktiv in der Wikipedia mitgearbeitet, das ist allerdings schon drei Jahre her. Ich will allerdings erstmal auf was ganz anderes hinauf, also das ein bisschen mehr in die Metaebene geht. Was mir auffällt, nachdem ich diese Diskussion und alles das dazugehörige verfolgt hab in den letzten Wochen, dass ganz viele Leute sowohl auf der Seite der Wikipedia als auch auf der anderen Seite irgendwie das Gefühl haben, dass sich die Parteien gegenseitig zerfleischen wollen und gegenseitig schlecht reden. Also auf der einen Seite, Fefe's Block ist nicht relevant und das ist eine Armee von Trolls, die auf die Wikipedia einbäscht und auf der anderen Seite eben es gibt nur böse Wikipedia-Blockwarte, die alles löschen wollen und gegen Fefe sind. Ich würde sagen, dass das Ding, warum das überhaupt entstanden ist, ist aus ganz der gegenteiligen Motivation entstanden. Eine Person wie Felix von Leitner oder auch andere, die in diversen mehr oder weniger relevanten Blogs dazu Stellung bezogen haben, den liegt die Wikipedia sehr am Herzen und sie benutzen diese seit Jahren und wollen sie auch gerne weiter benutzen und wollen sie in einer Form haben, die wirklich ideal ist. Und daher denke ich, dass ein konstruktiver Dialog zwischen den beiden Seiten, ohne dass da irgendwie ein Bashing in der Form stattfindet, wie es bisher der Fall ist, wesentlich zielführender und hilfreicher wäre, um die Problematik, die offensichtlich da ist, zu lösen.
Ja, deswegen sind wir heute hier. Es gibt auch da dieses Telefon. Und damit nicht genug findet am 5. November eine Veranstaltung der Wikimedia statt, wo genau das diskutiert werden soll.
Genau, die Wikimedia hat da so ein bisschen eingeladen. Ich fand den Ton der Einladung so ein bisschen verbesserungsbedürftig, um mal Wikipedia-Deutsch zu benutzen. Aber wir werden da natürlich hingehen und versuchen auch mal ein bisschen konstruktiv Vorschläge zueinander. Da kommen wir später vielleicht im zweiten Teil, in der zweiten Stunde noch dazu, so ein bisschen mal darüber zu reden, was man dann eigentlich besser machen könnte. Aber gerade, würde ich gerne tatsächlich nochmal genau über diesen Punkt reden, den Blender gerade gemacht hat, nämlich, das ist tatsächlich so, also diese Wahrnehmung, dass die Netzwelt da draußen jetzt der Wikipedia feindlich gegenübergestellt ist, die ist halt komplett falsch. Das ist tatsächlich so, dass die allermeisten Leute machen sich einfach nur Sorgen um ein Projekt, das ihrer Meinung nach einfach irgendwo falsch abgebogen ist.
Wir haben irrsinnigen Autoren, also wir haben keinen Schwund, aber es geht alles zurück. Es gibt weniger Autoren, es gibt weniger Artikel, es gibt weniger Leute, die die Community stürzen. Und ich kann nur alle bitten, die sich beteiligt haben in der Löschdiskussion um Feifelsblog, geht auf Blogosphäre, holt euch die Bücher aus dem Schrank, die kommunikationswissenschaftlichen Lexika, was auch immer ihr da habt, irgendwelche Artikel und schreibt den Artikel Blogosphäre neu.
Also du sagst, ihr wollt eigentlich neue Autoren, aber genau was wir gehört haben, war ja, dass Leute, die versuchen neu hinzukommen, werden so in keiner Weise an die Hand genommen. Also zumindest, was jetzt passiert, wenn ich jetzt so naiv dahergestolpert komme, sehe halt so, hey, da kann editieren, ich editiere jetzt mal und mache einen Artikel, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der irgendwie entweder schnell gelöscht wird, also dass gleich weg ist, ist halt hoch.
Bei uns ist es halt so wie im Rest vom Netz, das sind hauptsächlich zornige junge Männer, denen du da begegnest und die sind halt ein bisschen emotionalisiert und beschimpfen dich dann halt und sagen, lad deinen Müll ja nicht rein in der Wikipedia, sonst kriegst du eine Sperre und bla, bla, bla, klar.
Du redest also auch von den Admins?
Ja, nein, von den Leuten, die für Admins gehalten werden natürlich. Also es sind oft auch ganz normale Benutzer, die halt eben in der Eingangskontrolle arbeiten, d.h. das neueste angucken, was da passiert ist, die neuesten Artikel, die neuesten Veränderungen feststellen, das passt ihnen nicht und dann irgendwie eine IP, nur weil es eine IP ist oder ein neuer Benutzer anbelaffen, in einen Ton, der wirklich zu wünschen übrig lässt.
Oh, wir hatten noch eine Plannerleitung.
Ja, der wollte anscheinend nichts mehr sagen. Vielleicht war es nicht relevant genug.
Warte mal, können wir da vielleicht kurz einhaken? Das ist nämlich auch so ein Ding, was die meisten Leute nicht so richtig verstehen und auch nicht sehen können mit den normalen Wikipedia-Einstellungen. Was gibt es da eigentlich alles für zornige junge Männer in den Dungeons, die da tatsächlich nur Trolle und Orks gibt? Oder gibt es auch immer Stichworte wie Admin, Sichter oder Bürokrator? Kannst du uns kurz die einzelnen Gattungen zeigen?
Es gibt ganz viele Rechte, die es überhaupt gibt, sie zu vergeben. Das Recht zu editieren hat jeder, das ist schonmal das Wichtigste. Wenn du angemeldet bist, hast du ein paar mehr Rechte, dann kannst du die Artikel bearbeiten, die nur für angemeldete Benutzer, die geschützt worden sind. Dann nach vier Tagen kannst du Dateien hochladen. Wenn du 200 Bearbeitungen gemacht hast, dann kriegst du die Stimmberechtigung. Das heißt, du darfst dich bei allen basisdemokratischen Prozessen mit einbringen, ob das Adminwahlen sind oder Meinungsbilder, sonstiger Art. Und dann darüber gibt es die Sichter, das ist neu eingeführt worden. Das sind Leute, die einfach nur auf den Knopf drücken und sagen, ja, okay, die letzte Veränderung war kein Vandalismus. Das hilft halt, dass Leute, die deine Mutter reinschreiben, in Artikel, dass das erstmal nicht gesehen wird. Dann gibt es die Admins. Die Admins können halt Artikel löschen und haben noch ein paar andere Zusatzrechte, können aber auch natürlich sperren. Also Konten dicht machen, weil Benutzer wird nie ausgeschlossen. Es wird immer nur ein Konto durchgemacht oder eine IP abgeklemmt.
Naja, oder auch ganze IP-Ranges, ne? Also ich meine, das ist halt auch so eine der Dinge, die wir sehr häufig hören, ist zu sagen, naja, manchmal möchte ich halt einen Artikel editieren und dann wird plötzlich mein ganzer IP-Range gesperrt. Oder und zwar völlig unklar, nach unklaren Kriterien, mit unklaren Auswirkungen. Und dann kann man halt erst mal da nicht mehr editieren.
Na ja, das ist einfach, dass jemand sich halt haufenweise irgendwelche Benutzerkonten anlegt, um die irgendwelche Leute beleidigen sollen oder halt irgendwelche Beleidigungen. Ein Artikel schreibt. Also ganz klassischer Vandalismus einfach. Und die Leute sind halt, ja, die haben halt Lust. Da ist ja eigentlich ein klassischer Troll so gesehen, aber er schadet halt immens, er bindet unglaublich viel Arbeitskraft, weil wir alles immer wieder zurückgängig machen müssen, was der macht, alles löschen, was der anlegt. Und dann muss halt mal eine Range abgeklemmt werden, weil da ständig wieder ein neues IP kommt. Das haben wir leider keine Alternative im Moment.
Ich würde mich jetzt mal interessiert sagen, also wir haben jetzt schon über Banalysmus und Trollen gesprochen, wie sieht denn so der Alltag eines Wikipedia-Admins aus?
Den Alltag eines Wikipedia-Admins kannst du gestalten, wie du magst. Du kannst im Grunde deinen Alltag...
Okay, wie sieht dein Alltag aus?
Mein Alltag sieht so aus, dass ich mich so, sagen wir mal, an einem Tag, in dem ich in der Wikipedia bin, verbringe ich da bestimmt mindestens drei Stunden und gucke mal in die Löschkandidaten rein, meistens in die letzten Arbeiten die ab, gucke in die Schnelllöschkandidaten rein, d.h. also Sachen, die schnell gelöscht werden, weil es einfach keine Artikel sind, weil es einfach Tests sind, also jeder kann ja einfach testen, das wird dann irgendwie wieder rückgängig gemacht. Und schlicht so irgendwelche Meinungsverschiedenheiten auf der Vandalismus-Meldung, das sind meistens neben den wirklichen Vandalen sind oft Benutzer, die irgendwie sich in die Haare bekommen haben und sich da wüsst beschimpfen. Und dann ist es halt nötig, mal einen Artikel kurz zuzumachen oder einen zu ermahnen, einen Benutzer, das halt mal mit seiner Wortwahl ein bisschen zurückhaltender sein soll, so Geschichten.
Das hört sich ein bisschen so nach Kindergarten an. Wie viel Zeit bleibt dir denn sozusagen, um so eine Lösch-Diskussion wirklich gründlich zu lesen und abzuwägen?
Lösch-Diskussionen, manche sind schon in 5 Minuten erledigt. Das ist, wenn jemand einfach sagt, fake, unbewiesen. Jemand anderes schreibt, ich hab nachgeguckt im Lexikon, das gibt's nicht, da brauch ich nur eine Minute, lese ich die beiden Sachen, der Artikel ist weg. Ich kann noch mal kurz ins Netz gucken, es dauert aber auch höchstens 2 Minuten, wenn da nichts auftaucht, dann hat jemand einen Fake eingestellt. Andere Sachen, die brauchen bis zu eine halbe Stunde, würde ich mal schätzen. Also wirklich alle Sachen durchzulesen, alle Argumente abzuwägen und dann noch mal selber ein bisschen zu gucken in irgendwelchen Datenbanken, ob die Geschichten alle stimmen, die die Leute gesagt haben und ob nicht doch irgendwelche anderen Sachen dafür sprechen, dass ein Lämmer bedeutend ist.
Da redest du gerade über die Quellenlage, also wie viel recherchieren musst, ob was in der Medikte eigentlich drinsteht. Da gibt es auch Hörer, die haben Fragen zu. Und der erste ist Verdi. Hi.
Hallo.
Tach, du bist jetzt im Radio, beim Chaosradio, wo wir über die Wikipedia reden. Und du wolltest etwas zur Wikipedia fragen.
Äh, bin ich jetzt gemein, ne?
Ja.
Ja, weil ich hätte eigentlich unter der Websee, egal. Äh, ja, ich hatte erst mal Fragen zu den Grundsätzen. Es hier Enzyklopedia, Neutral, Urheber, Recht und Recht und Respekt. Da wollte ich mal fragen, Enzyklopedia, wie ist denn das genau zu verstehen? Ich hab bestimmte Artikel gesehen, da weiß ich nicht, wurde auch noch drauf hingewiesen, so Kritik. Kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch, weiß ich nicht, einfach über, weiß ich nicht, ich sag jetzt einfach mal über einen Baumarkt schreiben, der halt immer in der Kritik ist und sonst was. Kann ich da auch was dementsprechendes reinschreiben? Kann ich da Verlinkungen machen? Also das ist ja, weiß ich nicht, zum Beispiel von Monitor oder sonst was. Kann ich da irgendwelche Verlinkungen mit reinpacken? Geht das ja oder nein?
Frage an den Adminen, wenn dir so ein Artikel über den Weg läuft.
Ein Artikel über den Baumarkt. Wir hatten, wir haben Artikel über diese, wie heißen die nochmal, diese Einkaufszentren, diese riesigen Dinge, diese Malls. Genau, also so ein Mall ist denke ich mal schon ein Bauwerk, das auf jeden Fall behalten wird. Andererseits spricht sie ohne Ende aus der Gegend. Irgendein normaler Baumarkt würde wahrscheinlich gelöscht werden. Wenn da nichts irgendwie bedeutende Architektur, größtes Sortiment, irgendwas in der Art.
Beantwortet das deine Frage?
Und wie sieht das aus? Ich sag mal, ist ja von, ich hatte mir das notiert, und zwar ist das von dem Herrn Larry Singer, wurde ja mal das Problem angesprochen, dass Wikipedia an sich das Problem hat. Und zum Beispiel, weiß nicht, in der Wikipedia steht was drin. In der Presse wird es aufgegriffen, wird das so zitiert. Und sag mal, es wird was in der Wikipedia verbessert, richtig abgeändert, aber von der Presse wird es wieder eingeschrieben.
Ich fürchte, das wird jetzt eine Diskussion auf ein ganz ganz ganz anderes Feld führen. Nämlich die Frage, wie die Wechselwirkung ist zwischen Wikipedia, klassischen Medien und den Leuten, die einfach am Netz Dinge abschreiben, ohne zu recherchieren. Da könnte man auch mal ein Chaosradio zumachen, aber das ist heute nicht unser Thema. Sondern wir wollen heute reden über die Wikipedia, wie die umgeht mit Artikeln, die gelöscht werden, weil sie angeblich oder vielleicht wirklich irrelevant sind. Und da ist ja auch ein Problem halt die Quellenlage. Und dazu hatte Andreas auch noch eine Frage.
Ja, ich möchte euch ein kleines Dilemma schildern, das ich habe. Also ich bin Mitautor von einem Artikel, der gegen Wikipedia-Kriterien verstößt. Und zwar dadurch, dass es Original Research ist. Konkret geht es um eine Artikelmusterung, wo ich, ich bin Österreicher, hab den österreichischen Teil dazu geschrieben. Er basiert auf persönlichen Erfahrungen. Die Details, die da drinnen sind, sind einfach undokumentiert, weil die gesetzliche Definition relativ groß ist und was dann tatsächlich passiert, basiert auf Dienstanweisungen, Ministerweisungen, etc.
Du musst darunter sagen, es geht um die Tauglichkeitsprüfung für den Wehrdienst.
Genau, die Tauglichkeitsprüfung. Diese Details werden natürlich aus strategischen Gründen nicht veröffentlicht. Es gibt auch keine zitierfähige Literatur. Also da hab ich einiges recherchiert. Allerdings hab ich aufgrund dessen, dass ich die Leute oder ein paar Leute, die da involviert sind, kenne, hab ich den Artikel quer lesen lassen. Die haben gesagt, okay, alles was drinnen steht, stimmt. Und haben dann noch ein paar Sachen ausgebessert. Obwohl das jetzt den Formalkriterien nicht entspricht, weil es Original Research ist und keine Quellen verfügbar sind, also das grundsätzliche Thema ist meiner Meinung nach trotzdem relevant, weil ja jeder, der 18 ist oder älter und männlich ist, ist damit konfrontiert worden.
Also der Nutzwert sozusagen.
Ja, also es hat fast jeder damit zu tun, knapp 50 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Und damit ist einfach eine gewisse Relevanz gegeben. Jetzt, Wolf, ich wissen, wie seht ihr das? Oder wie kann man dieses grundsätzliche Dilemma beheben?
Tatsächlich ein schöner Fall, der das noch fast klar raumschreibt. Als die anderen heute hatten, das ist ein Thema. Das betrifft tatsächlich ganz viele Leute. Gemustert wird einfach mal jeder. Es gibt dazu anscheinend keine Quellen. Trotzdem gibt es jemanden, der hat sich die Mühe gemacht, das zu arbeiten.
Wenn es keiner anzweifelt, dann bleibt das halt drin stehen. Bis zu dem Moment, wo es jemand anzweifelt, dann muss man auf der Diskussionsseite das ausdiskutieren. Und Sachen, die völlig klar sind, die müssen nicht belegt werden. Also bis zu dem Moment, wo jemand sagt, es kommt mir aber ein bisschen komisch vor. Und den Beleg fordert und in so einem Fall, wenn echt ums Verrecken kein Beleg beigefügt werden kann und nur jemand sagt, ich hab's aber so erlebt, dann muss das halt raus. Da können wir auch nichts machen. Warum? Weil das einfach nicht, weil das jemand nicht glaubt. Und weil der keine Belege dafür bekommt.
Aber dann kann ja die Wikipedia sozusagen immer nur nachgeordnet sein.
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht ganz.
Die Frage, wie man das sekundär... Können nur Dinge darstellen, die schon irgendwo anders mal gestanden haben? Okay, dann geht uns aber ziemlich viel verloren. Und ist nicht die Wikipedia eigentlich mal angetreten, um genau das sozusagen zu verhindern?
Nein, es ging darum, das Wissen der Welt sozusagen zu sammeln und allen frei zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und das Wissen, dass es halt schon gab.
Okay, Andreas, das heißt für dich, der Artikel bleibt bestehen, solange bis irgendjemand kommt und das anzweifelt, was du da erlebt hast.
Anzweifelt das österreichische Bundesheer.
In Zweifel genau dieses Jahr.
Ich hab den Artikel nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen geschrieben. Da kann ich nur hoffen, dass da keiner irgendwie da mal dazwischenfährt und irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich müsstest du versuchen, ihn in irgendeiner Studentenzeitung abgedruckt zu bekommen und dann auf diese Papierversion als Referenz zu verweisen.
Ich hab das schon überlegt, aber der Inhalt ist doch irgendwie zu plump, um das auch mal nicht zu publizieren.
Bei Google Noll reinschreiben, die haben ganz viel Platz für möglichen Geschichten und das wird wahrscheinlich auch bald im Ranking steigen.
Okay, aber bis dahin ist es tatsächlich so, er ist auf die Willkür, also es ist eine Willkürentscheidung, sobald jetzt irgendein Mensch das hört im Radio und denkt so, ha, geil, dem Andreas wische ich eins aus, ich zweifele einfach mal fett an, was er da reingeschrieben hat.
Da gab es einiges, da habe ich mich mit Gegnern der Stellung doch ziemlich streiten müssen und etliche Details, die aus meiner Sicht der Wahrheit entsprechen.
Also ich wäre auf jeden Fall dankbar, wenn du den Artikel schon mal irgendwie retten würdest, um zu gucken, dass er schnell in Dampf ziehen kann.
Zum Ablauf in Österreich Belege fehlen, Original Research.
Tja, vielen Dank aber trotzdem für den Anruf.
Eines möchte ich noch sagen, also grundsätzlich bin ich ja der Wikipedia sehr dankbar. Ich bin ja in gewissen Gräsen als der Österreicher, der alles weiß, verstrien. Und ja, diesen Ruf habe ich der Wikipedia zu verdanken.
Na dann, viel Spaß damit und nicht beim Kneipen-Quiz bescheißen oder was, wo auch immer du das einsetzt. Dein Allwissen. Aber noch mal zu dem Artikel zurück. Wir haben jetzt klar gemacht, ok, der Andreas hat das irgendwie selber sozusagen recherchiert und naja, wenn jetzt jemand anzeifelt, was da passiert ist, dann kommt das einfach raus. Gibt es denn für mich als benutzende Möglichkeit, wenn ich weiß, ok, es gab da mal diesen Artikel, da ist jetzt was raus verschwunden, den verschwundenen Teil zu sehen?
Na ja, du brauchst nur einen Admin zu fragen, also beispielsweise mich auf der Diskussionsseite und sagen hier der Artikel, der wurde gelöscht, schick mir den doch mal bitte zu. Dazu musst du allerdings angemeldet sein, dass ich ihn dir per E-Mail zuschicken kann oder du gibst mir halt einfach deine Mail auf der Benutzersite. Das haben wir aber nicht so gern, dass Leute persönliche Daten veröffentlichen. Also anmelden, mir eine Mail per Wikimail schicken oder auch einfach so fragen und dann stelle ich ihn in meinen Benutzernahmenraum kurz her, die Leute können sich den rauskopieren und dann wird er wieder gelöscht.
Ok, aber du sagst, es gibt keinen, zeige mir gelöscht Artikel an.
Nein.
Aber warum eigentlich nicht?
Es gibt ein paar Tools dafür, die gibt es schon, wie viel gelöscht worden sind und du...
Ich meine aber, warum? Das ist ja eine prinzipielle Frage.
Es werden täglich ein paar hundert Sachen gelöscht.
Na ja, bloß zumindest dark, also ich meine mal die Mühlhalde, warum ist die nicht öffentlich?
Es gibt ja die Deletionpedia, die gibt es leider noch nicht auf Deutsch und hier der Aufruf an alle Leute, die sich wirklich für die Wikipedia interessieren, macht eine deutsche Deletionpedia und holt alles rein, was von der Löschung bedroht ist und bleibt das Wissen erhalten.
Aber du sagtest ja selber auch, dass die Inhalte nicht wirklich gelöscht werden, sondern einfach nur sozusagen versteckt sind. Warum schafft man dann keine Möglichkeit, die anzeigen zu lassen?
Ich wüsste jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, was es da für einen Grund geben sollte.
Ja genau, den, den wir gerade die ganze Zeit diskutieren, das ist halt noch ein Fantasie.
Na ja, größtenteils sind die gelöschten Sachen ja wirklich Beleidigungen, veröffentlichen persönlicher Daten oder sonstiger Schrott.
Also es gibt da keine, ich sehe da, ja aber auch da wieder ist sozusagen, da geht es wieder der Grundsatz, wenn etwas sozusagen nicht seine Unschuld beweisen kann, wird es erst mal gelöscht und sozusagen mit dieser Argumentation, da gibt es viele Beleidigungen, landen dann halt auch einfach viele Sachen.
Also vor allen Dingen ist das ja völlig unproblematisch, man kann das ja kategorisieren, weil die Löschungen sind ja alle begründet. Also wenn man sich die Löschbegründung anguckt, dann treten natürlich die Sachen Beleidigungen oder persönliche Daten auf, aber die in den Orkus zu schmeißen, ok, da hat niemand was dagegen, aber warum sind nicht die Sachen, die irgendwie wegen mangelnder Relevanz oder wegen Original Research gelöscht werden, warum sind die nicht öffentlich, dafür gibt es keinen guten Grund.
Ja, es ist einfach der Grund, dass Wikipedia nicht das Projekt ist, das das auf dem Schirm hat. Also Wikipedia wollte halt eine Enzyklopädie sein, keine Datenbank, keine Halde für Artikel, die halt eben offensichtlich unbedeutend sind und insofern muss da jemand anderes ein Projekt dafür starten. Und das hab ich ja gerade gesagt, also die Wikipedia ist eine Enzyklopädie.
Heute am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wie immer das Chaos Radio zu Gast sind bei mir Frank Rieder. Frank Rieder von Chaos Computer Club. Ich bin Sago von Wikipedia Admin. Wir reden heute darüber, wie die Wikipedia funktioniert und die Frage, um die sich jetzt im Moment hanealaustriert ist sozusagen, da werden viele Sachen gelöscht und vielleicht will man die trotzdem sehen. Warum kann man die nicht angucken? Und Sago sagt, naja, dafür ist die Wikipedia eigentlich gar nicht da. Benny hat zu diesem Problem auch eine Frage oder eine Ansage. Hi Benny.
Es gab einen Anrufer, der hat vorgeschlagen, dass man doch einfach gucken könnte anhand der Zugriffszahlen auf verschiedene Artikel zu gucken, wie relevant die dort mit sind. Und da sehe ich eigentlich grundsätzlich das Problem, dass eigentlich erst mal alles an Wissen relevant ist und mal dann doch eigentlich eher in die andere Richtung filtern sollte, so wie es jetzt auch mehr oder weniger schon gemacht wird, zu gucken, was jetzt Beleidigungen oder irgendwie andere Sachen sind. Weil wenn jetzt immer nur rein nach der Zugriffszahlen oder der Wichtigkeit geht, dann tut man wissen, was eigentlich selten nachgefragt wird, nach einer gewissen Zeit irgendwo über den Jordan werfen. Und das geht der Welt dann insgesamt ja verloren. Nur weil es eben seltener irgendwo von Leuten beachtet wird.
Aber bist du in deiner Ansicht zu sagen, dass alles, was jemals drin stand, auch behalten werden sollte? Oder bist du dann auch für so Relevanzkriterien, also sagen nur Themen werden behalten, die bestimmte Kriterien erfüllen?
Ich bin erstmal grundsätzlich dafür, dass alles mitbehalten wird, weil mit den Relevanzkriterien und diesen 99 Prozent der Deutschen, die da uninteressant sind, da tut man eigentlich viel zu viel wissen, was die Menschheit mit hat. Dort erstmal von vornherein ausschließen.
Also die interessante Frage ist ja, wenn man sagt Popularität von Wissen, nehmen wir mal an, wir benutzen Popularität von Wissen als eine Messgröße, also als irgendein Wert für Relevanz. Nur mal ganz stumpf. Wir wissen alle, das würde dazu führen, dass der Britney Spears Artikel wahrscheinlich ungefähr 5 Megabyte groß ist. Aber wäre nicht zumindest Popularität eines Artikels, als Erschwerungsgrund für eine Löschung oder eine signifikante Kürzung des Artikels nicht eine sinnvolle Messgröße. Also man sagt, wenn ein Artikel zum Beispiel häufig verlinkt ist von außen, also das ist halt genau so ein Punkt, also der kommt auch immer wieder in Diskussionen, die wir so haben, ich schreibe einen Blog-Eintrag und ich referenziere auf die Wikipedia. Und dann ist plötzlich der Artikel halbes Jahr später weg, weil irgendwie er angeblich nicht mehr relevant ist. Was ja häufig auch passiert ist, dass Leute die Artikel nicht mögen, da passieren dann so Sachen, die kriegen sie im ersten Anlauf nicht so richtig weg, und dann werden die zu Tode gekürzt. Also dann wird immer eine Zeile nach der anderen abgebissen mit einer Bemerkung und am Ende wird der Artikel dann gelöscht wegen keiner Relevanz mehr. Das ist ja durchaus ein Vorgehen, was man durchaus beobachten kann.
Da gab es letztens auch mal ein Beispiel in der englischen Wikipedia, was da auch in dieser Diskussion rund um Moges und Fese aufgetaucht ist.
Und am Ende landen wir genau wieder da, dass dieser Anspruch, ein druckfähiges Lexikon zu machen, versus irgendwie ein Ding für die Netzwerke.
Ich muss sagen, das ist jetzt eine Position, mit der ich mich sehr schwer auseinandersetzen kann, ist zu sagen, wirklich 100 Prozent der Deutschen sind relevant. Weil ich viele Personen kenne, die mit Sicherheit nicht wollen, dass da die Wikipedia ein Personenverzeichnis wird, in dem wirklich alle Personen aufgeführt sind. Es hat auch ein bisschen was mit Daten zu tun oder so. Mit der Position kann ich mich eigentlich wenig auseinandersetzen.
Ich möchte kurz sagen, für alle Leute, die nicht wissen, warum jetzt gerade über alle Deutschen reden, es gab einen, also einen der Blockartikel, die dazu verlinkt und viel gelesen wurden, hieß, 99 Prozent aller Deutschen sind irrelevant. Ich glaube aber, dass man sagen kann, das ist natürlich eine provokante Bemerkung und niemand will wirklich, dass irgendwie alle Deutschen in der Wikipedia stehen. Was ich jetzt gerade spannend fand, war diese Löschgeschichte. Also irgendwie Leute kürzen Artikel, ist das sozusagen, also umsatzweise, dann wird irgendwann gelöscht, weil nicht einfach nicht genug drin steht. Ist das ein Vorgehen, was passiert?
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Ausnahme, aber klar passiert das. Also da habe ich auch schon mitbekommen. Muss man halt dagegen stehen und das dann eben wieder zurücksetzen und letztlich dann, wenn er wirklich keine Sachargumente hat. Also teilweise sind die Kürzungen auch Verbesserungen, weil vorher ist es halt ein Geschwurbeln, Geschwafeln, Ellenlanges, bla bla, mit Tausenden von irrelevanten Belegen. Und wenn da jemand das irgendwie kurz und knackig zusammenfasst, dann wirkt so ein Artikel fast schon bedeutender, als er vorher war. Weil ja, aber oft ist das auch bös gemeint. Das stimmt schon, das passiert schon. Einer ärgert sich über den anderen und macht in seinen Artikeln rum und versucht sie halt schlecht zu machen. Das gibt es, klar.
Benni, du meinst ja sozusagen, eigentlich sollte möglichst viel drinstehen und möglichst wenig löschen. Bist du denn selber in der Wikipedia aktiv?
Selber aktiv nicht, außer für ein Oben-Source-Projekt, was ich dort selber mit betreue und wo es in der Wikipedia eine Eintracht dazu gibt. Und das auch in der Wikipedia relativ stark benutzt wird sogar als Plug-in.
Okay, magst du noch kurz erzählen, was das ist?
Geysi, der Generic-Sündachs-Highlighter, also womit in den ganzen Programmierartikeln zum Beispiel die Sündachsvervorhebung für Beispielquelltexte gemacht wird.
Alles klar, dann sag ich auf jeden Fall mal vielen Dank für deine Arbeit. Denn es sind genau diese Leute, die es möglich machen, dass die Wikipedia in diesem großen Rahmen überhaupt funktioniert.
Ja, wollen wir mal Boris reinnehmen?
Wir wollen mal Boris reinnehmen. Tschüss Benni und hallo Boris.
Ja, hallo.
Ja, du wolltest was vorschlagen, glaube ich.
Ja, und zwar eher ein Vorschlag zu Güte. Und zwar gibt es ja schon seit längerem diese geprüften Artikel. Ihr hattet auch schon darüber geredet, dass die einmal kurz rangegesehen werden und ob dann nun was viel Veränderungen stattgefunden hat, ja oder nein. Wo ich auf jeden Fall zustimme, ist, dass Artikel gelöscht werden sollten, wo persönliche Daten veröffentlicht werden oder rein das Geschwimpfe ist. Aber ein Großvorschlag wäre doch tatsächlich, wenn man als Normalbürger auf die Wikipedia geht, kriegt man halt die normalen Artikel, aber wenn man sich angemeldet hat, kriegt man die ungeprüften Artikel und das kann ja auch wirklich die gesamte Bandbreite sein.
Dann hätten wir wieder ganz schön viel Kram.
Hättest du das für denkbar, sozusagen, es gibt so einen wissenschaftlichen Kern und eine...
Naja, das hätte den Vorteil, dass unheimlich viele Leute sich anmelden und vielleicht auch ein, zwei Sachen dazu beitragen, so Wikipedia, weil ohne Autoren schläft das ganze Ding ja ein.
Gibt es denn da so eine Diskussion innerhalb der Wikipedia, so was mal zu wagen?
Naja, ich meine, im Moment ist es ja so, es gibt über 300 Admins. Also ich kann nur sagen, bring dich ein, schreib gute Artikel. Dann wirst du Admin, dann kannst du alles sehen.
Nee, plus die Frage ist ja, ob so ein Vorgehen nicht sinnvoll wäre. Also dass man sagt, okay, es gibt Sachen, die sind halt gerade populär, die werden von den Leuten als momentan wichtig angesehen. Und da weiß man aber noch nicht, ob es langfristig bedeutet, zum Beispiel Piratenpartei. Der war 2006, war das ein Dush-Kandidat. Mit der Bemerkung wird eh nix. Also das war halt so im Wesentlichen das Fazit der Löschdiskussion. Und wie wir gerade sehen, hat die Piratenpartei mittlerweile eine Relevanz erreicht, so selbst nach allen Wikipedia-Kriterien. So und die interessante Frage wäre jetzt, ob man nicht sagen könnte, okay, wir gehen halt hin und sagen, wir bauen einen Gütesiegel, also sozusagen einen Kern der Wikipedia, der halt irgendwie den Brockhausansprüchen genügt und haben ansonsten aber noch einen Wikipedia-Light, wo halt einfach die Relevanzkriterien nicht ganz so hoch gehängt werden und von mir aus auch die Freiläge Feuerwehr hinter Butzendorf drauf ist. Wenn die Leute sich halt drum kümmern und die Artikel, sagen wir mal, wesentlich formal korrekt sind.
Formal korrekt, sondern halt viel kümmern. Wir sind im Moment, ich weiß nicht, ein paar tausend Leute nur, die sich um die ganzen Sachen kümmern. Und die Pflege ist halt das hauptsächliche Problem. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt zehnmal so viele Leute wären, dann könnten wir vielleicht auch die...
Aber da beißt sich doch die KZNR 20. Wir haben doch gerade gehört, dass die Leute frustriert sind und aufgeben, weil sie keine Möglichkeit haben, sich einzubringen, sondern erst mal extrem hohe Hürden haben.
Ja, aber es gibt auch zum Beispiel Leute, denen es völlig egal ist und die sich selbst eine Meinung bilden möchten. Und wenn die die Möglichkeit haben, alle Artikel zu sehen, nun ausgenommen von den wirklichen Beschmutzungen, dann möchte ich das auch wirklich sehen. Egal, ob das nun jetzt eine tolle Enzyklopädie ist oder nicht. Ich möchte zumindest die Möglichkeit haben, die Artikel zu sehen. Und das muss ja auch nicht sofort auf der Startseite da sein.
Na ja, also wie gesagt, das für mich wäre halt so eine Klassifizierung zu sagen, okay, der Artikel entspricht jetzt nicht den Relevanzkriterien, aber ansonsten ist er nicht beleidigend, aber es ist halt irgendwie keine persönlichen Daten drin, ist halt nicht enzyklopädisch relevant, aber zumindest ist er lustig.
Ja, es schafft halt eben zusätzliche... Also ich sehe das immer aus dem Admin-Auge. Das heißt, ich müsste jetzt nicht nur entscheiden, bleibt der Artikel, wird der Artikel gelöscht. Arbeite ich den Artikel in einen anderen Übersichtsartikel ein, diese Möglichkeit besteht ja auch immer, sondern verschiebe ich den jetzt auch noch in diesen anderen Namensraum, in denen nur bestimmte Benutzer Zugriff haben. Das heißt, ich habe dann irgendwie wieder eine neue Bürokratie und wieder neue Richtlinien, an die ich mich halten muss.
Genau, genau, das Gegenteil wäre der Fall, wenn man sagt, Artikel, die ihr halt nicht in zu... Naja, ich meine, versucht nochmal gerade aus dem...
Ich schreibe jetzt einen Artikel über dein Hemd, stell den dann da ein und dann bleibt der da. Wem soll das denn nutzen? Das ist doch kein Wissen.
Hey, ich meine, du weißt nicht so über mein Hemd, aber vielleicht habe ich hier gerade genau das T-Shirt hinter aller Hafenwurfe.
Das detailliert ja auch keinen, den Artikel. Und deswegen guckt auch keiner rein. Also, wen stört es? Das ist doch wirklich... Platzverbrauch kann es echt nicht sein.
Naja, das ist so ein bisschen so... Da beißt sich halt die Katze in den Schwanz. Ihr sagt ja, Wikipedia hat zu wenig Leute. Das ist ja auch immer das Argument dafür, wieso der Wissensraum begrenzt sein soll. Also de facto, wenn man jetzt das Argument mal schön zuspitzt, sagt man, sagt ihr, wir haben nur so viele Lämmer, oder Lämmerter, wie wir maintainen können. Also wie wir tatsächlich irgendwie gewartet bekommen. Und wenn man aber sagt, wir senken jetzt mal zumindest für einen Teil des Namensraums einfach die Kriterien, dann entsteht da plötzlich eine ganz neue Gruppe von Autoren, die in der Lage ist, halt einfach Sachen zu schreiben. Und da kann man immer noch gucken, wer was taugt und wer Schrott schreibt.
Ja, es werden halt viele, viele Wikipedianer abhauen. Die werden dann wirklich zu Neul gehen oder die werden doch noch bei Wikivise einziehen oder so. Wir haben ja ungefähr das Mantra, dass man nichts aus der englischsprachigen Wikipedia übersetzen kann, weil die Artikel halt unseren qualitativen Ansprüchen nicht genügen. Und die Qualitätsautoren wollen wir natürlich auch unbedingt behalten. Wir wollen vor allen Dingen neue Qualitätsautoren auch gewinnen. Also Leute aus der Wissenschaft, die irgendwie an der Uni sind. Das können von mir aus auch Erstsemester sein, wenn die wissen, wie man in der Bibliothek recherchiert. Und die Leute wollen wir natürlich auch nicht verlieren. Und die werden gehen. Also den Prozess gab es ja schon. Es gab ja schon mal eine Fawke von Leuten, die gesagt haben, die Qualität in der Wikipedia reicht denen einfach nicht. Die wollen jetzt wirklich nur Zitierfähiges veröffentlichen.
Ja, bloß genau da sind wir mit einem zweiten Kernproblem. Also wenn ich jetzt eine Studienarbeit in der Uni entreiche oder eine Magisterarbeit und habe da Wikipedia-Verweise drin, dann kriegt die um die Ohren gehauen und zwar zu Recht. Das heißt, das Ziel der Zitierfähigkeit ist ohnehin nicht erlangenbar?
Nein, das ist nicht gewünscht.
Nein, das ist de facto nicht erlangenbar.
Wir wollen das auch gar nicht, weil wir wollen ja weiter, dass jeder sein Wissen einbringen kann.
Aber de facto, also ich meine, bloß da passt es ja gerade nicht.
Genau, wir bewegen uns ja so Wattebausch-mäßig halt in verschiedene Zwiebeln, in verschiedene Interessen. Also wir wollen nicht zitierbar werden. Das heißt, wir wollen nicht, dass gar keiner mehr mitschreiben kann, aber wir wollen, dass jeder, der ein bisschen was an Material zusammentragen kann, das halt auch in die Wikipedia packen kann und damit allen zugänglich machen. Darum geht es ja.
Na, aber das scheint ja mittlerweile nicht mehr der Kern des Ganzen zu sein. Also wenn ich jetzt an diesen Artikel im Wikipedia-Kurier z.B. denke, der ist leider jetzt schon gelöscht, aber...
Der ist nicht gelöscht, der ist in der Visionsgeschichte immer jederzeit abrufbar.
Na gut, also jedenfalls ist er jetzt nicht mehr vor, auf der Frontpage zu sehen, der da sagte, Blogs werden im Wesentlichen von Prekariat und zweitklassigen Wissenschaftlern betrieben.
Genau, ich hab Prekariat verlinkt übrigens in dem Artikel.
Aber dann sagt man halt, ok, eigentlich wollen wir den Pöbel da draußen ja nicht. Also wir wollen auch das Wissen des Pöbels nicht und wir wollen auch nicht die Arbeitskraft und die Artikel, die wir schreiben könnten, sondern wir wollen halt nur Leute mindestens mit einem akademischen Abschluss. Aber offensichtlich gibt es ja einen großen Bedarf danach zu sagen, ok, da wir die Wikipedia ohnehin nicht zitieren können und sie nicht den wissenschaftlichen Ansprüchen genügt zitierfähig zu sein, ist das dann nicht eine Illusion, die da betrieben wird? Also zu sagen, wir versuchen jetzt hier einen Zitierfegen?
Das ist jedenfalls nicht greifbar.
Es scheint mir so, dass die Diskussion dahin geht, wie viel nehmen wir jetzt rein eigentlich? Du sagst, Sargo, der Wikipedia-Admin sagt, wir nehmen halt nur das rein, was wissenschaftlich belegbar ist, auf Papier gedruckt und mit Quellen. Und viele Leute draußen sagen, das muss eigentlich schon viel mehr sein. Es ist jetzt auch gerade der Unterschied gefallen zwischen, du hast gerade erzählt, Sargo, die englische Wikipedia, da darf man keine Artikel übersetzen, weil die den Qualitätskriterien nicht genügt sind.
Nein, das ist so ein Bormor im Ende-Deutschsprachigen Wikipedia.
Aber genau um diesen Unterschied geht es auch Streethoff. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ja, hi.
Du willst etwas zum Unterricht zwischen Englischer und deutscher Wikipedia sagen?
Auf jeden Fall. Also erstmal schönen Gruß an den Blaine. Den hab ich schon echt lang nicht mehr gehört. Ist auch ein alter Hanoveran aus der Leitstelle 511 bei uns.
Okay, so viel zu den Details, jetzt zur Wikipedia.
Jetzt zur Wikipedia. Ja, also ich guck zumindest erstmal in die englische Wikipedia, weil ich da viel, viel mehr finde, was mich interessiert. Problem an der deutschen Wikipedia finde ich echt diese Relevanzdiskussion. Das finde ich recht grenzwertig. Das ist eine offene Wissensdatenbank im Prinzip. Artikel löscht wegen einer Relevanz. Gegen einen Kumpel von mir aus Augsburg, ein Wikipedia-User, DK64, hat eingestellt letztes Jahr ein tolles Modul, was es für den Commodore 64 als neue Hardware gibt. Das nennt sich 1541Ultimate. Das ist eine Floppy-Emulation, die eine echte 1541 Floppy für den Commodore 64 emuliert. War damals dann halt so, hat einen super Artikel geschrieben, eingestellt, gelöscht von einem Atari-User, wieder eingestellt, wieder gelöscht.
Wir reden jetzt einmal noch von der deutschen Wikipedia.
Wieder eingestellt, natürlich in der deutschen Wikipedia. In der englischen, also er hat es dann später in einem reinen Commodore 64-Wiki eingestellt. Mittlerweile gibt es einen Artikel in der deutschen Wikipedia zu dem Modul, weil es anscheinend relevant genug ist mittlerweile. Die 1541 Ultimate halt.
Okay, wäre deine Forschung jetzt die deutschen, sollen so werden wie die englischen?
Also ich fand das halt damals traurig, weil der Artikel war gut. Guckt man sich an, 1541 Ultimate in der Wikipedia ist im Prinzip so ein Artikel.
Wir wissen jetzt, dass du den Floppy-Controller total toll findest, aber wie sollte sich die deutsche Wikipedia in Zukunft verhalten, so wie die englische oder eigenen Stil entwickeln?
Ja gut, also ich fand das halt damals schade, dass aufgrund von Relevanz, derjenige hat die Hardware halt als Hobbyprojekt gebaut irgendwie.
Ich fürchte, wir kommen hier nicht mehr zum Punkt, sondern wir bleiben hängen bei einem 1441 Controller, was echt ein Controller für einen tollen Computer war. Aber genau, gut. Wir wollen jetzt aber herausfinden, was ist mit der Wikipedia, mit der deutschen Wikipedia? Wie stellt ihr euch vor, wie das sein könnte in Zukunft? Jens hat dazu auch was zu sagen. Tag Jens. Wie sieht deine Wikipedia aus? Wie hältst du sie gerne?
Also ich hab zwei Vorschläge zu machen. Zum einen wäre es vielleicht gut, von dem Blick auf eine Enzyklopädie jetzt mal zu abstrahieren. Also es wird immer gesagt, Wissensdatenbank, ja okay, aber da bietet das Internet doch mehr heutzutage. Also ich kann Wissen erfassen, ich kann Wissen vernetzen und ich kann Texts vergeben und so weiter. Und da könnte die Enzyklopädie doch einfach eine Untermenge der Wissensdatenbank sein. Und da müsste ich dann nicht so schnell zum Löschding greifen.
Das hört jetzt ein bisschen verschwobelt an.
Wikipedia zum Beispiel jeden Artikel erst mal behalten und nur löschen, wenn es absolut notwendig wäre. Und dann könnte man bestimmte Prädikate vergeben für Artikel, die sozusagen für eine Enzyklopädie-Version geeignet werden. Und dann könnte ich zum Beispiel anschalten, ich will suchen nach allen Artikeln oder ich will suchen nur nach Enzyklopädie-tauglichen Artikeln. So ähnlich wie vielleicht so ein Qualitätsmerkmal wie die gesichtete Version, sag ich mal.
Okay, Jens sagt also, in Wikipedia soll irgendwie alles rein und die Qualitätsunterschiede machen wir dann einfach durch Label durch, die da vergeben werden. Da ist Merlin nicht ganz der Ansicht. Hi Merlin.
Hallo.
Wie willst du die Wikipedia haben?
Ja, also ich bin im Grunde der Meinung, dass die Schnittmenge größer sein sollte. Also dass ja in der Tat mehr behalten werden sollte, wenn Artikel gut sind. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass beispielsweise Spezial-Wikis auf jeden Fall eine Daseinsberechtigung haben. Und man sollte Wikipedia nicht damit verwechseln, quasi als alles, als Google oder was auch immer. Google wird ja nicht umsonst allwissende Müllhalle genannt.
Das ist der Schwitzname, den ich für Wikipedia kenne.
Nee, das ist der für Google bei uns.
Manche sagen so, manche sagen so, du willst aber nicht alles in der Wikipedia haben, wo würdest du die Grenze ziehen?
Die Grenze ist natürlich immer eine schwierige Sache. Aktuell merkt man es ja, dass Fefe genau an der Grenze liegen, finde ich. Beziehungsweise darüber, aber spielt jetzt ja keine Rolle. Ich glaube eher, dass das eine Lösung des Konflikts wäre, das eben so ein bisschen ins Bewusstsein zu ziehen und eine bessere Vernetzung zwischen Wikis zu kriegen. Dass ich beispielsweise Star Wars Wikis oder South Park Wikis in irgendeiner Form gut verknüpft hab, damit ich einerseits in der Wikipedia, die so einen allgemeinen Bereich, wie man das jetzt genau auch immer definiert, einen allgemeinen Bereich abdeckt und die Spezial-Wikis dann eben den Rest machen. Beziehungsweise nicht den Rest, aber eben wesentlich spezielle Ideen.
Konkret der Fall, es ging hier um diesen Verein MOGIS, der wurde gelöscht und du sagst, wenn jetzt für die Löschung gesprochen wird, heißt das dann, es existiert in der Wikipedia dann ein Link auf das Spezial-Wiki, wo es einen Artikel dazu gibt oder wie soll das sein?
Die genaue Umsetzung, da weiß ich das, um alt zu sein, nicht. Ich wüsste nicht, wie man das realisieren kann. Ich bin da in der Form kein Techniker.
Aber das ist deine Vorstellung sozusagen?
Ja, ich stell mir das in der Form eher wie so ein Such-Interface vor, wie man das zum Beispiel auf wikipedia.de im Endeffekt hat, dass dann eben mehrere Wikis, viel mehr Wikis umfasst.
Wer soll dann deiner Meinung nach entscheiden, ob der Artikel in der normalen Wikipedia am Start ist oder in so einem Spezial-Wiki?
Mir geht es jetzt ganz konkret noch gar nicht um die Entscheidung, sondern eher um das Gesamt, also insgesamt um das Bewusstsein, dass eben Wikipedia nicht für alles ist, sondern so eine Gesamtmenge abgrenzt. Und die genauen Grenzen kann man eben nicht ziehen. Ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, ein guter Artikel über ein Thema, was vielleicht nicht ganz so relevant ist, auf jeden Fall behalten.
Also auf jeden Fall diese Entscheidung treffen und sagen, im Zweifelsfall...
Genau, ich brauche jetzt ja nicht von Wireshark oder so über irgendwelche Funktionen. Dann Artikel, der wäre ja in der Wikipedia völlig unsinnig und fehler am Platz. Der gehört dann eben ins Wireshark-Wiki.
Also Merlin sagt, Artikel trennen. Es gibt die ganz relevanten, die sollen bei der Wikipedia stehen bleiben. Und es gibt dann die, die so ein bisschen weniger relevant sind. Und die kommen dann in Spezial-Wikis.
Ich habe eine kleine Geschichte. Und zwar habe ich vor ungefähr drei Jahren, wollte ich bei uns auf der Arbeit auch so eine Wissensdatenbank einführen und habe meinem Chef davon erzählt. Und der war dann auch so, ja, das nutzt doch keiner. Und das sind irgendwie verwaiste Wissensleichen. Und er möchte so ähnlich wie die Wikipedia haben, dass quasi nur wichtige Sachen drin sind. Und das dann quasi damit abgetan. Und mein Argument dafür, was er dann auch akzeptiert hat, war, wenn es bei uns auf der Arbeit nur fünf Leute betrifft, die es interessant finden, dann hat es doch schon eine Relevanz. Oder dann ist es doch schon wertig. Und das hat er dann akzeptiert mit dem Argument, dass es, wenn es doch bloß eine Handvoll Leute interessiert, dann hat es doch einen Sinn.
Okay, aber wie viel wäre ein, also für die Wikipedia braucht man da irgendwie so ein Kriterium. Was würdest du sagen, wie viel muss eine Handvoll sein? Also reichen da wirklich so, wenn fünf Leute sich mal sagen, hier so, ich finde den Artikel interessant, dann ist gut?
Ja, wo du jetzt auf der Firma bleibst mit fünf Leuten bei 200 ist natürlich nicht so viel im Vergleich zum Internet. Aber im Prinzip ist es doch dann fast so gut wie alles. Abgesehen ist natürlich von Vandalismus und irgendwie Fäkalsprachbeschreibungen und sowas. Ist doch dann eigentlich alles wichtig, weil denen es interessiert, oder die Handvoll, die sind tatsächlich interessiert. Und wenn es nur 50 Leute sind, die sich für den Kleintierzüchterverein in Oberammergau interessieren, dann sind es eben nur die 50 und alle anderen stören sich im Prinzip nicht an diesem Artikel.
Okay, Mark sagt also auch, es soll in der Wikipedia all das reingenommen werden, was irgendjemand interessiert, solange es so eine Handvoll Leute ist, weil es stört ja keinen, wenn da mehr drin steht, was man irgendwie nicht genau lesen will. So, wenn ihr mal sehen wollt, wie ein Chat feiert, dann empfehle ich euch jetzt auf Chaosradio.de zu gehen, dort den Link zum Chat rauszusuchen oder ihr geht einfach direkt zu Freenode in den Raum Chaosradio, denn ich werde jetzt ankündigen, was nach den Nachrichten passiert. Was nach den Nachrichten passiert, ist, dass wir mit Fefe sprechen werden, auch vom Chaos Computer Club. Der hat ganz viel darüber geblockt mit dem Wikipedia-Problem. Vorher aber, wie gesagt, machen wir Nachrichten weiter... Oh Gott, es wird wirklich Zeit, dass die Nachrichten mit Weiter- und Verkehr kommen. Außerdem spielen wir noch einen Song vorher, der sich von Frank Rieger, der heute hier zu Gast ist, gewünscht wurde, wo ich mich ja gefragt habe, wenn man die Chaos Leute fragt, was soll man machen, hauptsache elektronisch, das Rest ist eigentlich Latte, aber immer wenn die so einen speziellen Wunsch anbringen, dann hört sich das überhaupt gar nicht elektronisch an. Magst du kurz sagen, was wir gleich hören?
Genau, wir hören gerade gleich die norwegische Band Katzenjammer, die neulich durchs Netz geistert war. Wir haben es ja manchmal hier mit schönen jungen Frauen, mit großen Bessen und die fallen auch in diese Region.
Das ist Katzenjammermusik, die noch nicht zu Ende ist anscheinend.
Ich glaube, wir können es abblenden.
Aber andererseits, diese schöne Musik, die hört im Chaos-Radio, wo wir gleich mit Fefe darüber reden werden, was ihnen in Wikipedia so stört. Vorher gibt es aber wie bereits angekündigt und wortgewaltig versprochen Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
So klang das Ende ihres exklusiven Fritz-Radio-Konzerts im September. Aber zum Glück liegt ja in jedem Ende ein neuer Anfang.
Fritz präsentiert die Editors.
Samstag, 21.
November. Editors, live in der Berliner Koloniale.
Karten gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt.
Zum Beispiel auch auf Hipstik.
Editors, live in Berlin und präsentiert von Fritz.
Und das hört man um kurz nach halb 12. Nachrichten mit Kaietan Dürlich.
Die neue Bundesregierung hat ihre Arbeit aufgenommen. Kanzlerin Merkel und die 15 Ressortchefs von Union und FDP legten ihren Amtseid ab. Bundespräsident Köhler hatte den Ministern die Ernennungsurkunden überreicht. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel wurde am Vormittag vom Bundestag für eine zweite Amtszeit gewählt. Am Abend traf sie im Rahmen ihrer ersten Auslandsreise nach der Bundestagswahl in Paris an. In Brandenburg haben sich SPD und Linke auf die Verteilung der Ministerposten verständigt. Die SPD bekommt fünf Ministerien, die Linke übernimmt als neuer Koalitionspartner vier Ministerposten. Der bisherige Finanzminister Speer von der SPD wechselt in das Innenressort. Neue Wissenschaftsministerin wird seine Parteigenossin Münch. Bildungsminister Ruprecht behält sein Amt. Die Linke übernimmt unter anderem die Ministerien für Wirtschaft und für Umwelt. Während des Besuchs von US-Ausministerin Clinton ist Pakistan vom schwersten Terroranschlag seit zwei Jahren erschüttert worden. Unbekannte zündeten eine Autobombe in Peshawar, die mindestens 90 Menschen tötete. 200 weitere wurden verletzt, als der Sprengsatz in einem belebten Geschäftsviertel detonierte. Clinton verurteilte die Tat als feige. Die Pakistanische Armee führt zurzeit eine Offensive gegen die Taliban durch. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation will 200 Millionen Dosen des Impfstoffs gegen die Schweinegrippe an Entwicklungsländer verteilen. Das kündigte WHO-Generaldirektorin Chan zum Abschluss eines viertägigen Besuchs in Kuba an. Im November könne mit der Verteilung bereits begonnen werden, hieß es, nach Angaben der WHO sind bisher weltweit etwa 5000 Menschen an der Krankheit gestorben. Zum Fußball Bayern München hat das Viertelfinale im DFB-Pokal erreicht. Der deutsche Rekordmeister gewann beim Eintracht Frankfurt mit 4 zu 0. Ebenfalls weiter sind Schalke 04 und Werder Bremen. Die Bremer besiegten Kaiserslautern mit 3 zu 0. Schalke kam ebenfalls zu einem 3 zu 0 Erfolg bei 1860 München. In einer weiteren Achtelfinalpartie bezwang Hoffenheim den Zweitligisten Koblenz mit 4 zu 0. Heute Nacht, da ist es wieder ziemlich bewölkt draußen. Es kann immer wieder regnen und die Temperaturen fallen heute Nacht bis auf 6 Grad ab. Hier sind die aktuellen Werte in Cottbus und Angermünde. Da sind es aktuell 8 Grad. Trotz dem Frankfurt Neuropin Wittenberge immer noch 9 und in Berlin Werte zwischen 9 und 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann in der ersten Tageshefte ziemlich bewölkt sein. Später lockert es langsam ein bisschen auf. Und es wird morgen wieder ein bisschen kühler werden in Berlin und Brandenburg. Und das mit Höchstwerten von gerade mal 11 Grad. Bitte Vorsicht, alle die noch auf der Stadt Autobahn unterwegs sind, auf der A111 Stadt Einwerth zwischen dem Weidmanns-Osterdamm, Hermsdorfer-Damm und der Holzhoser Straße, da ist gesperrt, da wird geballt, äh gebaut, nicht geballt, gebaut. Und außerdem auch Richtung Süden auf der Stadt Autobahn zwischen dem Weidmanns-Osterdamm und dem Festplatz, da ist voll gesperrt. Da ist eine Umleitung ausgeschüllert. Und alle, die noch mit der Berliner U-Bahn unterwegs sind, die sollten auch passen, wenn sie mit der U1 fahren zwischen Gleisdreck und Wittenbergsplatz. Da fahren nämlich keine Züge. Am besten da an die Linie U2 ausweichen. Außerdem ist der Bahnhof Kurfürstenstraße gesperrt, geschlossen, nicht gesperrt, man kommt aber auch durcheinander. Und bei der U8 wird ab 10 Uhr zwischen Kottbursator und der Heinrich-Heine-Straße gependelt. Und das mit Bussen.
Können wir das einfach in Zukunft so machen, wenn die Verkehrsmeldungen leer sind? Wenn es mehr als zwei Seiten sind, sagst du einfach zu Hause bleiben?
Die waren doch fünf Seiten. Ne, zwei Seiten. Ich bin auch durch.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100 3, 2, dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Mit Markus Richter, das bin ich, der Moderator des Chaos Radio. Blue Moon natürlich zu Gast, jemand vom Chaos Computer Club, das ist Frank Rieder. Und dann noch jemand, wo im Chat gerade gesagt wurde, wer ist denn der arme Exkludist, auf dem gerade rumgehackt wird?
Exklusionist.
Eine weitere Frage. Möchtest du erklären, was mit diesem Wort gemeint ist?
Das ist eine kleine Spiegelfechterei. Der erste Eintrag bei den Relevanzkriterien, der sagt eben Exklusion, Inklusion, was sollen wir reinnehmen, was sollen wir rausmachen, Exklusion, Ausschluss. Ich bin ganz sicher kein Exklusionist und kein Inklusionist, sondern versuche halt einfach nur festzustellen, ob irgendwas eine gewisse Bedeutung hat. Und das möchte ich dann auch gerne behalten und ausgebaut sehen.
Also Exklusionisten sind Leute, die sagen, eigentlich muss alles raus, was nicht knallhart irgendwie total geil ist.
Oder super geschrieben.
Oder super geschrieben und inklusive Nerven, da hab ich auch schon, egal. Andere Diskussionen, jetzt gibt es auch noch die Inklusionisten, die sagen, eigentlich muss alles rein, was irgendjemand irgendwann mal irgendwie interessiert hat. Und das sind die beiden Leute, die sich in der Wikipedia streiten, denn das ist das Thema, was wir heute noch, naja, 24 Minuten knapp besprechen. Die Frage, was muss denn alles in die Wikipedia und was soll draußen bleiben? Und wir haben jetzt am Telefon einen, der, ich will nicht sagen Verursacher, aber sozusagen jemand, der die Diskussion vorangetrieben hat, könnte man sagen. Hi, Fefe. Guten Abend.
Also erst mal muss ich euch von einem Linguistik-Professor mitteilen, dass es Excludist heißt und nicht Exclusionist.
Ja, das außen vielleicht in der Wikipedia heißt es Exclusionist. Ja, beides hab ich, also beides hat kaum, kaum, kaum Ergebnisse, wenn du das suchst. Weder bei Google Scholar noch irgendwie Google Books. Also es sind beides Begriffe aus dem Luftlernraum.
Das können wir ja mal in allerlöscht Diskussion ausreinbartieren. Also, ja, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist, dieses Relevanzgetägen, da gibt es eigentlich ein ganz anschauliches Gegenargument gegen. Und zwar hat Google und eigentlich alle großen Suchmaschinen und Metasuchmaschinen inzwischen das so, dass wenn man nach irgendeinem Wort sucht und es gibt einen Wikipedia-Eintrag, dann ist der ganz oben. Ja, und das ist eine Sache, das ist eigentlich eine Multimillionenindustrie, das Webseitenkontext kriegen und wenn man sich überlegt, dass es so weit ist, dass Wikipedia einfach immer ganz oben ist, dann muss man auch die Relevanz andersrum sehen. Das ist nämlich nicht die Sache, die Wikipedia für relevant hält, sondern die Sache, die in Wikipedia gesucht werden von den Leuten. Und das sind dann einfach die Sachen, die in Google gesucht werden natürlich. Weil einfach mehr Leute bei Google irgendwas fragen als Wikipedia. Und wenn Wikipedia einen Alltag hat, ist der ganz oben. Das heißt, dieses Selbstverständnis, was Wikipedia da hat, kommt meines Erachtens daher, dass Google nur linked, wenn Google weiß, was Wikipedia was hat. Ihr seht einfach gar nicht, wie viele Leute Sachen suchen, die ihr nicht habt. Und daher diese Überlegung, dass man einfach Sachen, die man selbst nicht für relevant hält, nicht in die Wikipedia macht, die ist aber nicht zielführend an der Stelle. Denn ihr macht das ja nicht für euch, sondern ihr macht das für eure Zielgruppe. Und eure Zielgruppe sind durch diese Regelung alle Leute, die Suchmaschinen benutzen. Und das müsst ihr euch vor Augen halten, wenn ihr da rumiditiert in der Wikipedia. Deswegen hab ich neulich geblockt, dass ich finde, Relevanz sollte anders definiert werden. Nämlich, dass man sagt, wenn das, was im Artikel steht, mit dem Thema nichts zu tun hat, also wenn da irgendwie Blabla steht, oder irgendwie Frau Schmidt ist doof, und die Schüler vandalisiert hat, keine Frage, das kommt raus. Aber ansonsten, wenn das mit der Überschrift was zu tun hat, sollte man das als Relevant ansehen und den drin lassen. Ich bin der Meinung, als ich mein, ich werd häufig von Wikipedia-Dotten angesprochen in letzter Zeit. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Und eine der häufigen Sachen, die da kommt, ist eben, ja, aber es gibt doch diese Relevanzkriterien, die stehen in der Wikipedia drin. Und das stimmt auch, die kann jeder mal googeln, Wikipedia Relevanzkriterien ist der erste. Und das ist eine L-Lange-Liste. Also bei mir stoß da zum Beispiel, was war das Beispiel, was ich hatte, ich glaube Sinsa oder so was, Weinhersteller, es gibt für jeden Kack, gibt es da irgendwie einen Unterabschnitt. Und das sind ja keine ehrenlosen Gesetze, die von Gott gegeben, auf dem Mount Sinai, den Menschen auf Steintafeln gegeben wurden, sondern das haben auch irgendwelche Leute irgendwann definiert. Und so muss man das sehen.
Lass mich mal kurz zusammenfassen. Also im Prinzip hast du zwei Ansprüche an die Wikipedia, wie die Artikel sozusagen aufnehmen sollen. Wenn Leute das wissen wollen, und zwar absehbar aus irgendwelchen Google- oder Suchmaschinesuche, dann soll es dazu auch einen Artikel geben. Und wenn der Artikel sozusagen so geschrieben ist, dass er tatsächlich was aussagt und mit dem Wort zu tun hat, worüber der Artikel benannt ist, dann soll das drin bleiben.
Genau, also ich gebe mal ein Beispiel. Wenn ich jetzt hier rumlaufe und ich siehe die Frauenkirche, okay, das ist halt ein bekanntes Merkmal, das gibt es in Wikipedia. Und jetzt gehe ich irgendwie drei Häuser weiter. Ich bin dann in Dresden dran. Und da steht die Gemäldegalerie. Und gut, das steht jetzt vielleicht auch noch drin. Da habe ich nicht geguckt. Aber ich würde sagen, da findet sich irgendein Haus, wo irgendein Schild vorsteht. Und ich möchte jetzt wissen, was ist das für ein Haus? Und da würde mir schon völlig reichen, wenn da drin steht, das ist ein Haus aus dem Barock gebaut von dem und dem dann und dann. Das würde mir völlig reichen. Also ich erwarte gar nicht, dass da von enzyklopedischer Länge irgendwie die Details drinstehen, wie viele Treppen es da gibt und so. Das beziehe mich da alles nicht. Aber einfach schon so zwei, drei Grunddinger, die drinstehen, würden mir schon völlig reichen. Ich meine, die Frage ist, ich kann auch immer noch weggehen. Wenn ich hingehe zu Wikipedia, ich finde diesen Artikel und da steht nichts drin, was mir geholfen hat, dann gehe ich weg, da ist doch kein Schaden entstanden.
Aber würdest du dann auch sozusagen Relevanzkriterien anwenden, im Sinne von, auch dein Beispielhaus war jetzt aus dem Barock und wurde von jemand gebaut, das einen Namen an vielleicht schon mal gehört hatte, oder darf man dann wirklich zu jedem Haus einen Artikel schreiben?
Naja, das Problem ist, dass es da namensfreie mit Kollisionen gibt. Also zum Beispiel ganz normale Menschen Namen. Da gibt es halt, weiß nicht, wie viele Heiko Schmidt es in Deutschland gibt, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also da muss man irgendwo eine Linie ziehen, das sehe ich schon auch so.
Okay, wer soll entscheiden?
Na das muss man eben in Ruhe ausdiskutieren. Ich will das auch nicht entscheiden. Aber ich sage, wenn es irgendwas gibt, wo ich was zu google und da gibt es keinen Artikel, dann wäre ein Artikel ein beliebiger Artikel mehr wert als diesen nicht existierenden Artikel. Und ich finde, in dem Moment, wo ein Mehrwert denkbar ist durch einen Artikel in der Wikipedia, sollte man den auch nicht löschen, wenn es ihn gibt. Selbst wenn er grocken Scheiße und voller Rechtsschreibfehler ist.
Na gut, das brachte ich glaube ich noch mal ein weiteres Thema zu diskutieren, ob man das dann wirklich behalten wollen würde. Aber auf jeden Fall mehr Artikel und zwar immer dann, wenn sich jemand interessiert. Die Frage, die ich mir jetzt gerade stelle, ist so, also tendenziell, gefühlt würde ich sagen, ja, ja, aber wer soll das alles machen?
Das Problem ist ja, dass die Leute im Moment schon versuchen, sowas zu machen. Also dieser Commodore-Mensch war ein gutes Beispiel. Das ist ein absolutes Randgruppen-Ding. Da werden vielleicht 100 Leute im Jahr, wenn es hoch kommt, draufklicken. Aber für die ist das ein Mehrwert. Und deswegen finde ich, wenn...
Ich habe heute mehr Hitz bei meinen Artikeln.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt, den ich versucht habe vorhin zu machen, dass wenn man mehr Leute zulässt mitzumachen, dann löst sich genau dieses Problem auch.
Das irritieren wir im Moment nicht. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht meine Mail vorlesen, aber ich kriege im Moment echt viele Mails von Leuten, die mir also alle als Grundthener schreiben, ja, ich habe ja auch mal bei der Wikipedia mitgearbeitet, aber habe vor einigen Jahren aufgehört, weil mir diese barbaren Diskussionen mit den Lösch-Adminen zu blöde waren. Und ich meine, ich will es jetzt hier nicht irgendwie, das ist sicher nicht der einzige Mensch, der Standdienste gibt, aber da sind also signifikante Anzahl von Leute, meldet mir das gerade. Und das kann man nicht einfach irgendwie beiseite legen und sich dann auf der anderen Seite wundern, dass die Anzahl der Leute, die mitarbeiten wollen, abnimmt. Ja, also das hat Frank schon sehr richtig gesagt, das beißt sich selber in den Schwanz. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen, dass mehr Leute mithelfen, dann müssen wir eben auch die Schranke dafür senken, dass mehr Leute mitarbeiten wollen. Und das Erste, was man tun kann, ist, wenn man öffentlich kommuniziert. Ja, wir sehen, dass es hier ein Problem gibt mit der Intervanz und dass Artikel gelöscht werden, in die andere Leute, die ihr Herzensblut investiert haben. Und natürlich gibt es da immer Probleme, wenn irgendjemand einen Marketinger hochlegt oder so. Das bestreitet sich ja gar nicht, das kann man alles ausdiskutieren. Aber so, wie es im Moment ist, dass jemand sich da einen Tag Zeit nimmt, um einen schönen Artikel zu, was weiß ich, von mir aus sogar ein Produkt, ein Computerspiel, irgendwas, was wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht relevant ist. Ein Computerspiel von jemandem, zum Beispiel eines von Hardrock-Klienten. Also bei mir ist es durchaus so, dass ich bei der englischen Wikipedia mir irgendwelche Computerspielartikel durchlese. Und die haben in der Encyclopädie nichts verloren. Aber das ist ein echter Mehrwert für mich. Weil da steht dann drin, der Publisher, so und so, das ist dann und dann erschienen. Die Ratings waren so und so, mit Link auf Metacritic oder was weiß ich. Das ist ein echter Mehrwert. Und das finde ich gut, dass die englische Wikipedia das hat. Und wenn wir Deutschen da nicht so deutsch wären, an der Stelle, sondern einfach mal so ein bisschen relaxer rangehen würden, dann wäre die Wikipedia für Mehrleute ein Mehrwert. Und dann würden noch mehr Leute mitmachen wollen.
Ok, Fefe sagt also auch, mehr Leute müssen da reinkommen. Und das geht nur, indem es irgendwie niedrigere Relevanzkriterien gibt. Was er jetzt auch als Beispiel wiedergebracht hat, ist ja dieses sozusagen, da kommt jemand, schreibt mit viel Herzblut einen Artikel und dann wird der gelöscht, weil er nicht relevant genug ist. Gibt es eigentlich nicht eine Möglichkeit, dass man sozusagen, bevor man überhaupt anfängt, Herzblut zu investieren, irgendwo die Frage zu stellen, ich möchte gerne einen Artikel zum Computerspiel Brutal Legend schreiben. Ist das relevant für euch?
Nee, es gibt immer wieder Leute, die das fragen und das ist leider vorher nicht feststellbar, weil es ist ja ein kollaboratives Projekt, das heißt du weißt nicht, wer da mitschreibt und du weißt nicht, wer noch irgendwelche Belege dafür bringt, dass es halt wirklich irgendwann mal eine Bedeutung hatte oder so. Und da kann man von vornherein, man kann natürlich bestimmte Sachen sagen, klar relevant, natürlich schreibt den Artikel irgendwie, macht ihn vor allen Dingen gut. Aber bei Sachen, die zweifelhaft sind, das vorher zu entscheiden, das kann ich mir gar nicht anmaßen, als Admin entscheide ich auch nicht, sondern das entscheiden die Benutzer. Ich lese mir die Argumente durch und stelle dann halt eben fest, in welche Richtung das hindert und entscheide sie entsprechend. Ich bin mehr ein Pegel.
Okay, dann der andere Punkt. Ich komme jetzt zur Wikipedia, bin neu und habe jetzt auch die Sendung gehört und denke so na okay, das ist anscheinend irgendwie schwierig. Wo gehe ich denn hin, damit ich sozusagen mehr, also ich habe keinen Bock irgendwie jetzt irgendwie die 3000 Relevanzkriterienseiten zu lesen. Gibt es irgendjemanden, der nicht wenden kann, der sagt hier bitte zeig mir mal, wie das geht?
Ja, wir haben das Mentorenprogramm. Also ich denke mal, wenn man Mentorenprogramm googelt, wird das wahrscheinlich auch in Deutschland Platz eins sein und da kann man sich anmelden, allerdings vorausgesetzt einen Benutzer-Account, den ich sowieso aus Datenschutzrecht, also aus Datengründen jedem raten würde, weil man seine IP braucht mehr nicht zu verraten. Also Account anlegen und dann Mentor suchen und der hilft dann weiter. Der beantwortet die dümmste Frage irgendwie.
Das ist halt so einer der Punkte, die mir immer wieder sauer aufstößt, ist, software-technisch ist irgendwie so die Wikipedia halt irgendwie so 2003 stehen geblieben. Also da ist halt irgendwie, also es gibt halt irgendwie keine also was man heutzutage aus anderen webbasierten Systemen erwarten würde, dass es halt so etwas gibt wie irgendwie Wizards, die einen an die Hand nehmen und einem sagen, ok pass auf hier, wir zoomen auch mal einen Link ein und so weiter. Das ist halt noch so ein Media-Wiki-2000-Style. Und wenn ich mir dann angucke, auf welchen Bergen Geld gerade die deutsche Wikimedia sitzt. Also die deutsche Wikimedia hat irgendwie in ihrem Rechenschaftsbericht 2008...
Sprachig, deutschsprachig, englischsprachig, ganz wichtig.
Also der Wikimedia Deutschland e.V. um mal präzise zu sein, sitzt auf einem riesigen Berg Kohle, laut ihrem letzten Rechenschaftsbericht, den sie letztes Jahr angeblich nicht ausgegeben bekommen haben. Weil die kriegen halt richtig viele Spenden rein. Und die Spenden können sie nicht nach den USA schieben, weil das geht nicht als gemeinnütziger Verein. Also betreiben sie einen Toolserver, ansonsten sitzen sie auf dem Geld. Warum wird dieses Geld nicht dazu investiert, mal die Hemmschwellen für Wikipedia zu senken, also für die Deutsche? Warum gibt es nicht mal Wizards, mit denen man Artikel anlegen für einfach, die einem sagen, wenn da Sachen kaputt sind? Warum wird nicht mal experimentiert mehr? Also in dem Sinne, dass man sagt, wir probieren einfach mal zum Beispiel so einen niedrigschwelligeren Namensraum aus, auf dem steht, hey, pass auf, die Artikel hier erfüllen keine enzyklopädische Relevanz, sondern sind einfach nur da, weil es die Leute vielleicht interessiert. Ich vermisse einfach so diesen Drive, zu sagen, hey, wir versuchen einfach mal mit der Zeit zu gehen. Stattdessen ist das mehr so ein jetzt ist da draußen dieses doofe Netz und jetzt sind sie alle sauer auf uns, was da sich so ein bisschen in den Diskussionen manifestiert.
Das mit dem Wursad habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Ich lege einen Artikel an und der sagt mir, pass auf, an den Artikel gehören Referenzen rein, an den Artikel gehören Belege rein. Hier ist ein Template für ein Bild, da möchte ich halt, wenn es ein Biologieartikel ist, einen Beleg über den Lebensraum und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Die Kategorien und Ansprüche sind ja da und die Informationen sind da.
Es gibt halt Millionen von Hilfeseiten und es ist einfach unmöglich, für 90 da reinzufinden. Also ich würde wirklich sagen, such den Mentor, alles andere macht im Moment wenig Sinn. Ich lerne jeden Tag dazu und ich hoffe auch, dass es nicht aufhört. Also jetzt in puncto Wikipedia.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen beeilen, weil es wird jetzt schon wieder knapp. Ich wollte noch die Frage stellen, also was Frank gerade meinte, die eine Möglichkeit, das Problem zu lesen, wäre Geld und Enthusiasmus drauf zu werfen und einfach auch mal die Technik zu verbessern. Die andere ist ja letztendlich, wird zumindest gesagt, funktioniert die Wikipedia demokratisch. Wenn sich jetzt genug Leute finden, die sagen, hey, wir wollen einfach die deutsche Wikipedia erinnern, wie geht das denn vonstatten?
Naja, das geht einfach, das ist halt ein basisdemokratisches System. Das heißt, wenn irgendjemand die Initiative hat dazu und sich ein paar Freunde vielleicht sucht, um zu sagen, hey, wir schaffen die Relevanzkriterien ab, wir machen das jetzt genau wie der Englischsprachigen, die Sachen müssen notable sein, das heißt also sie müssen würdig sein, notiert zu werden in der Wikipedia, dann startet er halt eben ein Meinungsbild und dann versammeln sich da die Leute, die sagen Pro oder Contra, also am besten viele Argumente aufbringen und dann wird das so entschieden und dann werden die gekippt und das wird das englischsprachige System übernommen. Funktioniert ganz einfach.
Okay, da müssen einfach möglichst viele Leute mitmachen. So, dann ist die Frage jetzt, was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn das alles versagt? Also da draußen im Netz gibt es genug Leute, die denken so, okay, mit der deutschen Wikipedia das funktioniert nicht, wir wollen jetzt auch nicht irgendwie das gesamte System unterwandern, das ist uns zu anstrengend, ich nehme jetzt auch nochmal Pfefe dazu. Also gibt es Alternativen sozusagen? Also kann man noch eine Wikipedia machen?
Ich fand das mit dem Verein vorhin gut, weil das machen wir nämlich schon teilweise, dass Sachen wirklich ins Vereinswiki exportiert werden, ins Unternehmenswiki exportiert werden, vor allen Dingen die Indiepedia ist auch sehr wichtig für Bands. Das funktioniert halt schon, das ist nicht so bekannt, aber das wird eigentlich schon gemacht und in den Hauptartikeln sind auch immer Links, also meistens Links zu den entsprechenden Fachpedias.
Aber die sind zum Beispiel nicht in die Suchmaschine integriert, was ein echtes Manko ist.
Ja, die Suchmaschine ist glaube ich ein bisschen sowieso, die wurde gerade überarbeitet, aber die ist immer noch nicht sehr gut.
Also ich meine, was ich erwarten würde ist, wenn ihr sagt, okay, wir splitten das ab in Fachpedias, dass die in der Suchmaschine drin sind, also wenn es jetzt zumindest irgendeine Art von...
Ja, eine bessere Vernetzung wäre sicher sinnvoll, weil das ist alles auf Einzelinitiative, also es sind halt immer einzelne Personen, die diese Wikis pflegen und es sind auch einzelne Personen, die dann halt eben in den Hauptartikeln das entsprechend verlinken und, ja, müsste man mal schauen. Das sollten halt eben auch irgendwelche gemeinnützigen Leute sein. Ich bin Privatleute, haben wir auch schon erlebt, die es einfach abschalten, das Wiki und so. Da muss man ein bisschen gucken.
Klar, es gibt ja diese, also zum einen diesen Export von Löschkandidaten, habe ich gesehen, also dass Löschkandidaten in solche Fachwikis rübergerettet werden. Aber, naja, ich meine, am Ende ist halt schon die Frage, wenn jetzt, sagen wir dir, die Enzyklopedisten bei der Deutschen Wikipedia halt bei ihrem, sagen wir mal, Meinungs- bei ihrer Meinung beharren und dann kann es halt schon passieren, dass das Netz halt, bzw. die Leute, die sagen, wir wollen eine Mehreren haben, sagt, wir machen jetzt mal eine Wikipedia Lite. Und forken halt, sagen wir, wir nehmen halt den Datenstand mit und gehen halt irgendwie, fangen halt nochmal von vorne an.
Wir haben ja seit mindestens fünf, weiß ich glaube, wenn man das allein macht, ist das überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, forken, kurz erklären, man nimmt seinen aktuellen Stand und macht von da aus in eine andere Richtung weiter und sagt, okay, wir nehmen den aktuellen Datenstand und wir setzen uns ein neues Set von Riegeln und machen halt weiter.
Aber wäre es dann nicht schon wieder so, wenn man sagt, okay, wir nehmen jetzt so viele Leute, dass wir es schaffen, die gesamte Wikipedia noch mal aufzubauen und dann anders weiterzumachen, wäre es dann nicht sinnvoller, wenn die einfach zur normalen Wikipedia gehen und da mitmachen?
Naja, es ist eben die Frage, ob das geht oder nicht. Wir würden halt einfach den Datenstand, den würde man ja einfach mitnehmen. Das ist ja das Schöne an der Wikipedia, ist ja freies Wissen. Das heißt also, der Datenstand ist ja einfach weiterverwendbar. Ich meine, das ist halt eine extreme Angelegenheit und ich würde das auch nicht unbedingt als erstes irgendwie in Betracht ziehen, aber so wie ich die Entwicklung der Diskussion sehe und auch genau dieses Problem zwischen Enzyklopädie aber dann doch nicht zitierfähig, das ist so ein inhärenter Widerspruch, ob es dann nicht vielleicht auch der Wikipedia, also der jetzigen enzyklopedischen Wikipedia leichter gemacht wurde zu sagen, okay, wir verschärfen unsere Relevanzkriterien noch mal einen Tick und kommen hin zu einer zitierfähigen Brockhaus Replacement Enzyklopädie, wenn es auf der anderen Seite eine populäre Wiki-Dingsda gäbe.
Es gibt ja, also vorhin sagte ich ja der eine, Karl Inner, mit den geprüften Versionen, die es gäbe, die gibt es noch nicht, das sind die gesichteten Versionen, die geprüften Versionen, die sollen darauf eigentlich hinauslaufen, dass halt eine Person, die von dem Fach wirklich Ahnung hat, dass alles bis auf die letzte Zeile prüft und dann freigibt. Ich persönlich finde die Entwicklung eigentlich nicht gut, muss ich sagen. Aber ich schätze, dass früher oder länger, also früher oder später wird das auf uns zukommen, weil die Leute, die halt höhere Qualität wollen, die setzen sich halt auch ziemlich stark durch.
Also kann ich vielleicht noch einen...
Ja, gerne.
Genau, also ich hätte gern den Wikimedia-Leuten jetzt mal praktisch öffentlich, on the record, zitiere ich, dass den Vorschlag unterbreitet, dass sie einfach die Deletionpedia aufbauen. Weil ich meine, ihr sitzt an der Datenbank, ihr habt die Daten, ihr habt die Bandbreite, ihr habt Geld, auf dem ihr sitzt, macht einfach eine Deletionpedia. Die Software habt ihr auch, die Toolserver habt ihr. Warum soll das jemand anderes machen? Also wir haben jetzt in Deutschland, weiß nicht, was hab ich, es gibt dieses Waste-Dings irgendwas, also es gibt einen Typ, der das gemacht hat, aber der ist vielleicht am ersten Tag erschlagen worden von der Bandbreite, als ich auf den gelinkt hab. Und es gibt irgendwie diese Marjorie-Links, naja, ich mein, das ist halt nichts, was man nach ihm stemmt. Der CTC könnte das vielleicht machen, aber wollen wir das? Ich mein, eigentlich nicht. Im Grunde sitzt Wikimedia auf den Servern, die das können, auf der Software, die das kann, und sitzt auch direkt an der Datenbank und könnte sich selbst triggern, um die gelöschten Artikel einfach rüber zu puken. Und wenn wir das machen, dann haben wir quasi alle Bausteine schon zusammen, dann können ruhig die Qualifizisten in der Haupt-Wikipedia glücklich werden. Und dann haben wir im Grunde alle Vorschläge mit Minimalaufwand erschlagen. Kann auf denselben Server laufen. Also das ist meines Erachtens die billigste Lösung, die es überhaupt gibt. Und dann der Schritt zwei, was ich vor ein paar Wochen schon mal vorgeschlagen habe, aber da kann ich am Radio nochmal sagen, wäre, dass wenn du auf einen gelöschten Artikel gehst oder nach einem suchst und da gibt es einen Artikel, aber der ist gelöscht, dann steht halt nicht, gibt es nicht, sondern dann steht halt dieser Artikel, der ist gelöscht worden, weil wir ihn für, was weiß ich, unrelevant oder schlecht halten. Wenn du ihn trotzdem sehen willst, klicke hier. Weil wenn du das hättest, dann seid ihr A, also ihr Wikipedianer mit euren Qualitätsanforderungen. B würde es aber trotzdem Leuten geholfen werden, die irgendwas suchen. Also ich meine, das kann man ja alles vereinbaren.
Was man dazu sagen muss, ist, dass die englische Deletionpedia enthält keine Artikel, die beleidigend sind oder wegen Datenschutz gelöscht worden. Das ist halt ein wichtiger Punkt, um dem einmal gleich zuvor zu kommen. Sondern worum es halt geht, sind tatsächlich Artikel, die eben...
Na ja, eben, perfekt, passt doch alles. Also das ist meines Erachtens eine minimale Sache. Das kann ein Typ an einem Tag hatten.
Siehst du da irgendwie eine Chance für sowas? Ich bin nicht von Wikipedia.
Ich bin nicht mein Mitglied.
Aber innerhalb der Wikipedia...
Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz sagen, Sargoth ist ein Admin der Wikipedia, macht das sozusagen aus freien Stücken und ehrenamtlich. Und Wikipedia, also der Verein, der sich quasi um die deutsche Wikipedia kümmert, ist nochmal eine andere Sache. Aber natürlich gehen an die die Forderungen raus, weil es gibt zwar nicht wirklich einen Schuldigen in der Wikipedia, aber es sind doch die Leute, die am ehesten die Mittel haben, wie mir scheinen will. Und die haben am 5.11. auch ein Treffen.
Genau, am 5.11. Die Räume sind noch nicht ganz klar, muss man noch mal googeln. Dann am 5.11. findet eine Diskussion statt genau über diese Themen. Wo ein paar Leute, du bist auf dem Podium?
Also ich hab mich als Nachrüber gestellt, weil ich eigentlich nicht wirklich Lust habe.
Okay. Ja, ich denke von uns werden eine Menge Leute da sein. Mal gucken. Wir diskutieren gerade eine ganze Menge Vorschläge, halt wie zum Beispiel die Legionpedia, aber halt auch eben zu sagen, okay, in einem softeren Namensraum, aber auch so Sachen, wie zum Beispiel Löschen schwieriger machen. Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht aufmachen, nicht fast, aber einfach, sagen wir mal, die Hemmschwelle für...
Na die ist schon sehr hoch. Also die Leute haben oft nach ein paar Monaten keine Lust mehr, in der Löschwelle sich zu bewegen, weil sie wirklich übel sind.
Wegen der Diskussion?
Naja, weil du wirst halt einfach übelst beschimpft, obwohl du sachlich Argumente abgebogen hast. Also das hatten wir auch glaub ich irgendwie so, der Kasus knackt, das ist halt eben, wenn es zu Beleidigungen kommt, dann verliert man häufig die Lust.
Ja klar. Also gut, ja, aber okay, es gibt da jedenfalls eine Menge Diskussionsvorschläge. Interessanterweise sind viele von denen ja auch schon innerhalb der Wikipedia gekommen. Also ich hab irgendwie ältere Blogpostings von 2007 gefunden, wo halt genau diese Relevanzdiskussion zum Beispiel schon mal aufgemacht wurde und so. Teilweise auch von Leuten, die in der Wikipedia sehr aktiv waren. Und dann stellt sich dann immer so ein bisschen der Eindruck eines ziemlichen Beharrungsvermögens ein, so als wenn sich so der Konsens sehr glacial bewegt.
Ja, so ist das halt.
Also da ist ja doch schon so ein Soziotop entstanden, ne?
Ja, es hat sich aber auch ziemlich viel verändert. Also dieses Hippieske, was so früher irgendwie so ein bisschen in der Wikipedia war, das ist halt mit dem Eingang des Mainstreams so ein bisschen weggekommen. Also die Sachen sind auch viel härter und werden halt viel verbissener gesehen. Ich glaube, es sind halt viele neue Benutzer dazugekommen, die halt eben gerne Artikel schreiben, aber mit diesem ganzen Open-Source-Umfeld oder so mit diesem freien Wissensgeschichte, mit dem, was es halt bedeutet, konsensorientiert oder mindestens kompromissorientiert zu arbeiten, sich erstmal einfinden müssen.
Und dann gibt es noch einen weiteren Termin. Die Wikipedia-Diskussion ist an dieser Stelle natürlich nicht beendet. Das ist wieder eines von diesen Themen, die kann man in zwei Stunden gerade so anreißen. Ihr könnt auf jeden Fall weiter mitmachen. Am 5.11. wie gesagt, ist diese Diskussion. Er kommt außerdem Sargoth, die kann man auf der Wikipedia auch erreichen, wenn man Fragen hat.
Ja, genau, der Benutzer-Diskussion, die ist immer offen, die wird nicht für IPs zugemacht.
Sargoth wird geschrieben dann mit TH noch am Ende.
S-A-R-G-O-T-H, genau.
Ansonsten noch kurz den Werbeblock. Wir haben wieder ein Kongress am Jahresende zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, den Chaos Communication Kongress. Da wird es auch vermutlich ein größtes Diskussions-Podium zum Thema Wikipedia geben. Also das Thema beschäftigt uns da weiter. Ansonsten macht der Chaos Computer Club auch am 5.11. nach der Wikipedia-Diskussion noch einen Datengarten in den Räumen der Marienstraße 11 zum Thema Computerspiele am Beispiel von Stalker. Ja, Markus.
Da bin ich wohl dabei.
Da bist du wohl dabei. Gehen wir nach der Wikipedia-Diskussion hin. Ja, und ansonsten erreicht uns auch den üblichen Medien.
So sieht es aus. Diese Sendung gibt es außerdem als Podcast auf Chaosradio.de und auf Fritz.de auch. Und ich gebe hiermit ab an die beiden Irren von der Mittwochnacht. Das sind nämlich HerrSmiss und HerrSmart. Und wenn ihr die schon gehört habt, wisst ihr, die sind nicht ganz knusper. Heute wird es noch ein bisschen härter. DJ Morgoth haben sie mitgebracht. Auch so ein Mashup-Freak von Booty Berlin. Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie hier machen wollen, aber Ohrenstöpseln könnten gut sein, sonst fängt es an zu bluten. Ich verabschiede mich nochmal mit meinem Lieblingssong zu dieser Sendung. Website von Trekkie Birthday.
Tschüss.